Ah, Pogu, oder auch nicht.
Moin Leute, sehe ich schon wieder viele am Start direkt, 15 Sekunden nach Stream einschalten.
So, die Platz machen, exzellent.
Und, habe ich irgendwas die Woche verpasst?
Ich habe wieder nichts großartig mitgekriegt, was die Woche gewesen ist.
Wir müssen gleich mal eine Runde GitHub trennen.
Was ist denn das da unten, warum ist das hier nicht bündig auf der Seite?
Zack, mal reloaden.
Ah, yes.
Aha.
Das ist ein Bug, wenn man Fullscreen macht, guckt mal.
Direkt Ticket aufmachen bei Twitch.
Hier.
Broken.
Broken AF.
Nicht, dass es jetzt wirklich schlimm wäre, aber da hat auf jeden Fall,
wenn ihr irgend...
Einer bei Twitch Probleme mit CSS gehabt.
Was man verstehen kann, weil CSS ist mittlerweile auch richtiger Abfuck.
Hey, jetzt ist es weg.
Okay, was auch immer.
Das muss man jetzt nicht verstehen, oder?
Gucken, gucken, ob es wieder da ist, wenn ich...
Jetzt ist es wieder da?
What the fuck?
Das hat was damit zu tun, ob das Fenster aktiv oder inaktiv ist.
Jetzt ist es wieder weg.
Okay.
Da scheint, da scheint grundsätzlich was...
Nicht ganz richtig zu sein auf der Seite, wenn das durch pures Fenster aktiv und inaktiv machen, kaputt machen kann.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht wirklich schlimm, dass da unten ein schwarzer Strich ist, ne?
Ähm, weißer Strich auf schwarzem Hintergrund.
Twitch schafft es bei mir nicht, den Cookie-Banner auszublenden.
Also selbst, selbst wenn du die Cookies akzeptierst, vermute ich mal.
Tja.
Ja.
Aber die Seite ist manchmal schon ein bisschen, bisschen broken.
Das, ja.
Das, das, das kann tatsächlich daran liegen.
Weil, dass das irgendwelche JavaScript-Sachen blockt.
Du kannst aber, wenn du FFZ installiert hast, kannst du auch ziemlich viel ändern, wie die Twitch-Seite aussieht.
Also, vielleicht kannst du es auch da einfach ausblenden lassen.
Mal kurz gucken, ob das Cookie-Banner kann.
Ne.
Aber das kann irgendwelche Banner ausblenden.
Aber da scheint nur im Chat.
Unique ID.
Ist es jetzt, ist es jetzt gut oder schlecht, wenn ich die leake?
Okay.
Ich meine, ich meine...
Ich bin nicht eingeloggt.
Nicht, dass da was passieren kann.
This feature.
Ah, okay.
Das stimmt.
Generell muss man sagen, CSS ist mittlerweile extrem komplex.
Also, ich gucke ja manchmal, manchmal Videos auf YouTube von so, so diese...
Es gibt ja mittlerweile komplette Channels, die sich mit CSS beschäftigen.
So und...
Da hast du dann sowas wie...
Wir bauen jetzt...
Das und das nach.
Und da siehst du teilweise irgendwelche CSS-Selektor und Sachen und so, wo du denkst, was macht das jetzt eigentlich?
Also, CSS ist mittlerweile wirklich so eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Ich muss, ich muss aber echt mal sagen...
Also, ich meine...
Ich bin seit so ziemlich dem Anfang dabei, was das Internet angeht.
Zumindest, wenn es, wo es angefangen hat, für die Leute verfügbar zu sein.
Ja, also ich hatte meinen ersten Internetanschluss, glaube ich...
1900...
Na gut, das war noch mit Modem.
Das war noch mit Modem wahrscheinlich so 1995 oder so.
96, 1996, irgendwie so rum.
Da war ich, glaube ich...
Ja, da war ich 12 oder sowas.
Und...
Also, ich habe die Entwicklung mitgekriegt, gerade was Webbrowser angeht.
Und natürlich hat man sich auch damals schon, wo ich klein war, mit bisschen HTML und CSS und Webseiten erstellen und sowas beschäftigt.
Einfach, weil es cool war.
Ich bin gerade erst aufgestanden.
Ich denke mal, das wird sich gleich wieder ändern.
Und...
Eins muss man ja echt mal sagen.
Also, was sich browsertechnisch getan hat, die letzten 15 Jahre, ist schon heftig.
Also, generell die ganze Zeit.
Aber am Anfang, am Anfang gab es ja noch nicht mal richtig, richtig JavaScript.
Danach gab es einen Browser mit JavaScript.
Netscape, Netscape gab es auch noch.
Ja, Netscape.
Ich weiß sogar...
Ich weiß sogar noch, die Zeiten, als Firefox...
Ich meine, das war natürlich off...
Obviously nach Netscape, ja.
Aber ich weiß noch, als Firefox noch Firebird-Browser hieß.
Also, das wissen die wenigsten noch, aber...
Aber Firefox hieß mal...
Firebird.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch übrigens der Grund, warum das Mail-Programm Thunderbird heißt.
Mozilla Firebird.
Guck.
2000, 2000, äh, 2003.
Und dann wurde es irgendwann zu Firefox in 2004 umbenannt.
Also, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Also, das ist wirklich schon eine ganze, ganze Weile her.
Und was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, ist, es hat sich wirklich gut entwickelt.
Man kann sich da beschweren über vieles, aber...
Gerade JavaScript, nach den Ausgeburten der Hölle am Anfang,
ist das mittlerweile gar nicht schlecht.
Und da kann sich das C++...
C++-Gremium auch mal eine Scheibe abschneiden.
In JavaScript werden fast aus...
Fast, äh, nicht alles, aber fast ausschließlich sinnvolle Neuigkeiten, also sinnvolle Neuerungen eingeführt.
Und meistens auch so, dass man sie irgendwie versteht.
Nee, du, danke schön für den Sub.
Also, die machen komplett das Gegenteil vom C++-Gremium.
Das C++-Gremium denkt sich, wie können wir die 18. Art, was zu machen, einbauen,
aber implementiert auf eine komplett andere Art, sodass keiner sich irgendwie den Reim drauf machen kann.
Und JavaScript, das JavaScript-Gremium,
also der, der, was ist das, dieser ECMAScript-Standard-Zeug, wie auch immer die genau heißen,
Möb und Nier, du, danke schön, massive subscriptions hier,
die bauen sinnvolles Zeug ein.
Das letzte Beispiel ist zum Beispiel die neue DateTime-Library oder neue DateTime-Functions in JavaScript.
Die sind tatsächlich ganz okay jetzt.
Vorher war es ziemlicher Abfuck.
Aber mittlerweile ist es ganz okay.
Ist alles in Ordnung?
Ja, wenn man sich mal, JavaScript-History.
Es gibt doch bestimmt so eine Übersicht über Major Changes.
Sekunde, ich will nicht geblendet werden.
Und die nicht Major Changes-Übersicht oder sowas.
Da sieht man, dass die wirklich sinnvolle Sachen gemacht haben.
Hier, JavaScript-Versions, okay.
So, also wirklich, so wirklich interessant wurde es eigentlich ab hier.
Und so richtig, so richtig aufwärts mit den JavaScript-Stongs ging es ab ES6.
Aber man muss sich mal überlegen, JSON-Support ist erst seit 2009, ja.
Haben sinnvolle Sachen eingebaut.
Dann gab es Let und Cons, Default-Parameters, Array-Find, Array-Index, neuen Operator, Array-Includes.
Und das ist, das ist alles sinnvoll.
Wobei, da fehlt, da fehlt ja die Hälfte.
Da fehlt ja die Hälfte an Changes.
Es gibt viel mehr.
Ja, wow.
Hier irgendwas.
Sinnvolles drin steht.
Ja, das kann man seitens sagen, alle.
Naja, zumindest, die haben es wirklich, das hat sich wirklich gut entwickelt, JavaScript, über die letzten Jahre.
Und ich muss sagen, mittlerweile programmiere ich in JavaScript wirklich ganz gerne.
Also, ich würde sogar so weit gehen, dass ich sage, meine Lieblingsentwicklungsumgebung oder Lieblings-Environment,
ich meine damit jetzt nicht meine IDE, sondern so als Basis,
ist nach wie vor...
Nach wie vor C-Sharp, beziehungsweise irgendwas auf .NET-Basis.
Ähm, und das Zweitliebste, nachdem ja Ruby mittlerweile überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt ist,
Ruby ist immer noch eine super Sprache und ich mag Ruby allerdings,
mit dem, also diesem Abstieg von Rails,
macht keiner mehr was in Ruby.
Und ich muss ehrlich sagen, das Zweitliebste ist mir fast tatsächlich JavaScript mittlerweile.
So blöd es klingt, aber das ist gar nicht übel.
Also JavaScript ist schon okay.
Also, mir ist es lieber als Go, zum Beispiel.
Weißt du, das wird jetzt vielleicht die Go-Fans treffen, Go ist auch in Ordnung.
Aber, wenn ich mich jetzt entscheiden müsste, zwischen, äh, machst du mal schnell was in JavaScript,
oder machst du mal schnell was in Go, dann würde ich eindeutig JavaScript nehmen.
Wobei man aber auch der Fairness halber sagen muss, also, es gibt zwar ein paar Überschneidungen,
aber Go und JavaScript nimmt man schon oftmals für ein bisschen unterschiedliche Sachen.
Es hat aber alles seine Vor- und Nachteile, muss man ehrlich sagen.
Deswegen sollte man einfach das nehmen, was von der Technologie her passt.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man irgendwelche Standalone-Tools bauen will, dann ist Go einfach ungeschlagen.
Also, wenn du zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel, ein praktisches, praktisches Beispiel bei mir von der Arbeit, was ich gebaut habe.
Und zwar, wir benutzen ja Prometheus und Alert Manager und Node Exporter und Zeug für Grafana für Monitoring-Sachen und auch Alerting.
Also sprich, wenn zum Beispiel irgendein Service ausfällt,
dann kriegt unser Support eine Meldung über den Alert Manager geschickt.
So, und was jetzt öfters passiert ist, dass Leute zwar Wartungsarbeiten angekündigt haben,
aber das Wartungsarbeiten waren, die im Monitoring auffallen und sie haben im Vorfeld vergessen,
den Host oder den Service in Maintenance, nee, wie heißt das, Silence heißt es beim Alert Manager,
so eine Silence im Alert Manager zu setzen.
Das hatte dann den Nachteil, dass jetzt angekündigte Wartungsarbeiten waren, keine Ahnung, Zertifikatsaustausch,
so, und dann haben sie das Zertifikat ausgetauscht und währenddessen den Webserver neu gestartet.
Dann hat das Monitoring angeschlagen und der Support war getriggert, weil Monitoring, das war eigentlich nichts kaputt.
So, und dann habe ich was gebaut oder wollte ich was bauen, wollte ich ein Tool bauen, wo du, wenn du auf dem Server selbst eingeloggt bist,
sowas quasi machen kannst hier, Set Downtime, sinngemäß, ja, dass du sowas eingeben kannst auf dem Server
und dann setzt er einfach für dieses System 15 Minuten Maintenance.
Weil das wurde so oft vergessen, habe ich mir gedacht, wenn auf jedem Server ein Tool ist, was Set Downtime heißt, dann kann man das machen.
So, und dann habe ich das natürlich erst mal in .NET gemacht, weil ich mir gedacht habe, so easy, einfach am einfachsten.
Das war halt dann irgendwie am Ende 80 MB oder so groß, weil es halt das komplette Framework und alles wieder dabei war
und selbst getrimmt mit allem war es, glaube ich, immer noch 50 und das hatte auch auf ganz alten Red Hat Systemen Probleme, war halt Müll.
Und dann habe ich das Ganze nochmal neu in Go gemacht.
Set Downtime so, genau, das könnte da aber keiner schreiben.
Zumindest habe ich das dann nochmal neu in Go gemacht und da hat man wirklich mal die Stärken von Go gesehen.
Da kam am Ende dann, keine Ahnung, 6 MB oder so, was ja, sagen wir mal so, was für jetzt die C und C++ Leute immer noch triggernd viel ist,
6 MB für ein kleines, kleines Binary, ja, aber da kam irgendwie so ein 6, 7 MB Go Binary raus und das lief einfach überall, war easy zu benutzen, easy hinzuschieben.
Also für solche Standalone Sachen.
Ist Go sehr gut und ich glaube, das ist auch ein bisschen der Grund mit, warum das im Cloud Umfeld so beliebt ist, weil das kannst du einfach,
da ist es halt wichtig, dass die Dinger Standalone sind und dass die Dinger sich einfach voneinander deployen lassen und dafür ist Go wirklich gut.
Ich muss sagen, die Sprache an sich, die ist okay, aber wirklich zu meinen, zu meinen Lieblingen gehört Go jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Ist deine aktuelle Stelle schon ausgeschrieben?
Nee.
Ist nicht?
Nicht ausgeschrieben, weißt du warum?
Weil es schon einen Nachfolger gibt.
Das war ja auch mit der Planungs, Planungsspezial schlecht bei uns auf der Arbeit, also ich jetzt, ich kann das ja mal kurz erzählen.
Also, die wissen ja schon eine ganze Weile, dass ich abhaue, das ist ja wirklich nichts Neues.
Also ich habe denen das auch schon erzählt, bevor ich bei den Neuen unterschrieben hatte.
Ich hatte ja noch einen anderen Vertrag zur Auswahl und im Vorfeld war ich auch schon unzufrieden, dass ich gesagt habe, ich gucke jetzt, die wussten das, die wussten das, so.
Und jetzt kommt es, jetzt kommt es, also beste, beste Planung überhaupt wieder.
Ich hatte jemanden im Team, der wurde dann versetzt, nennen wir es mal, ein anderes Team.
Diese Stelle in dem anderen Team haben sie am Ende des Jahres gesagt, besetzen sie nicht mehr neu, das war ein, das war ein extern zugekaufter, sie verlängern seinen Vertrag nicht, dann war er weg.
Obwohl sie sich eigentlich letztes Jahr schon überlegt haben.
Der könnte doch dann die Sachen von Max überlegen.
Also lief es jetzt darauf raus, der war erst in meinem Team, dann war er in einem anderen Team, in dem Team haben sie ihm gesagt, sie brauchen ihn nicht mehr, dann haben sie den Vertrag nicht mehr verlängert und dann war er Ende des Jahres weg.
Und Anfang des Jahres ist ihnen dann eingefallen, oh, stimmt ja, der Max geht ja, wir sollen den mal wiederholen.
Und da haben sie den dann versucht, quasi eine Woche später, nachdem sie ihm quasi den Vertrag nicht verlängert haben, Anfang des Jahres wieder zu erreichen, ob er nicht wieder zu uns kommen will.
Das war auch wieder, wo ich mir gedacht habe.
Also man könnte das alles irgendwie ein bisschen weicher und weniger planlos handeln.
Ich meine, ich verstehe, warum es so gekommen ist.
Also mein Chef konnte den nicht vorher einstellen, weil es ja irgendwie offiziell noch keine Kündigung gab, was auch immer.
Aber da hätte man doch mal ein bisschen flexibel sein können, oder?
Also wisst ihr, sobald der Punkt gekommen ist, ja, richtiger Manager-Painstamp, sobald der Punkt gekommen ist, wo man Nachteile in Kauf nimmt,
von denen man weiß, dass sie kommen werden, aber aufgrund irgendeines Prozesses es nicht besser handeln darf, weil der Prozess sagt, du musst es schlecht machen, dann stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Deswegen, das ist auch der Grund, bis wohin Prozesse sinnvoll sind.
Das ist alles sinnvoll, dass man quasi einen definierten Arbeitsablauf hat, dass die Leute wissen, wann, wie, wo was gemacht werden muss, wunderbar.
Aber es wird immer der Punkt kommen, und das sagt ja auch jeder.
Das sagt ja auch jeder ITIL-Kollege.
ITIL, was haben wir da noch alles?
ITIL-Dings, SAFE und es gibt ja tausend verschiedene Super-Agile-Dinger und Prozess-Dinger.
So, das sagt ja jeder, dass Abläufe und Prozesse sinnvoll sind, allerdings du wirst nie alles hundertprozentig abbilden können.
Und es ist wichtig, dass das, was du machst, zum Unternehmen passt und dass du, wenn es drauf ankommt, auch mal was anders machen kannst.
Oh.
Aber das war anscheinend nicht möglich.
Ist das aber nicht gerade der Grund, warum du gekündigt... Was denn?
Doch, der ist wieder da.
Ah ja, die haben ihm wahrscheinlich massig Kohle bezahlt.
Ich wette mit euch, der kriegt jetzt mehr Geld als ich vorher.
Oh gut, der ist extern, der kriegt es auf jeden Fall.
Und wenn die mir das bezahlt hätten damals, wäre ich wahrscheinlich da geblieben.
Aber gut, hey, die Logik, das hinterfrage ich aber gar nicht.
Das haben sie ja komplett verkackt.
Ja, das ist auch... Also das muss man sagen, das versuche ich auch alles soweit möglich irgendwie ordentlich zu erklären.
Also ich habe ja ein paar Themen.
Ich glaube allerdings, dass es halt ein bisschen viel für ihn wird, weil er ja nicht...
Er macht ja noch Sachen von vorher, er soll jetzt meine Sachen machen plus noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Mal gespannt, was dabei rauskommt.
Ja, also ich habe jetzt noch zwei Monate Zeit.
Ah, nicht ganz.
Eineinhalb Monate Zeit, den ganzen Kram ihm zu zeigen.
Mache ich auch regelmäßig mal.
Passt eigentlich ganz gut.
Ob und wie gut das danach klappt, sei mal dahingestellt.
Ich werde es wahrscheinlich mitkriegen, weil...
Ich bin dann zwar nicht mehr dort in der Firma, aber ich meine, ich kenne die Leute ja noch und ich wohne 800...
Und ich wohne 800...
Ne, ich wohne nicht.
Ich arbeite dann 800 Meter Luftlinie weg.
Also ich werde mit den alten Leuten, mit denen ich mich gut verstanden habe...
Sind jetzt ja nicht so viele, wo ich mich wirklich gut verstanden habe, sondern drei, vier oder so, ja.
Mit denen gehe ich ab und zu mal was futtern, wenn ich da bin.
Ich meine, 800 Meter Luftlinie Entfernung ist jetzt nicht aus der Welt.
Da können die mir mal ein bisschen erzählen, wie es jetzt läuft und...
Ich kann ihnen das ein bisschen schmackhaft machen, ob sie nicht doch auch zu uns dann kommen wollen.
Achso, ja, das auch.
Also das ist tatsächlich der Hauptgrund.
Ich hatte übrigens, kann ich euch ja mal erzählen.
Ich hatte am...
Freitag hatte ich mein Exit-Austrittsinterview in der Firma.
Da, wo ich ja gerade arbeite.
Ich finde, Austrittsinterview hört sich ein bisschen an wie Gassi gehen, oder?
Weiß nicht.
Ich muss kurz austreten.
Zumindest gab es dann auch einen Fragebogen, so...
Was waren die Gründe, warum sie gekündigt haben?
Was hätten wir machen müssen, dass sie da bleiben?
Wie bewerten sie das und das und das und das?
Und ich bin gar nicht dazu gekommen, alles zu erzählen.
Die war viel zu schnell.
So nach dem Motto, nächster Punkt, nächster Punkt, nächster Punkt.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob die keinen Bock hatte.
Wobei die an sich wirklich sehr nett gewesen ist.
Also ich kann mir eher vorstellen, das ist nicht so erwünscht.
Das ist aber auch so ein...
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was ein Grund ist, warum ich keinen Bock mehr auf die Firma habe.
Die sagen immer, sie wollen was machen und wenn es dann darum geht, was zu machen, machen sie nichts.
Ich war an so vielen...
Ich meine, ich bin jetzt da über zehn Jahre da gewesen, ja.
Wir verbessern jetzt was und was können wir machen? Projekten.
Freiwillig.
Ich habe da immer freiwillig mitgemacht, beteiligt, ja.
Ich habe mal so ein...
Sogar mit Präsentation halten und vorstellen und allem.
Mehrfach.
Und es ist alles immer im Sande verlaufen und man hat sich ausgeredet.
Das geilste ist, ich weiß, die Story, Recycle-Story, die habe ich schon mal erzählt.
Aber das war...
Das ist für mich so das Musterbeispiel für, wie macht man es nicht.
Ähm...
Für alle, die es nicht kennen.
Ich erzähle es mal kurz.
Und zwar, wir hatten mal vom TÜV Leute da.
Der TÜV, der macht anscheinend nicht nur irgendwelche so Pflichtüberprüfung-Sachen, sondern du kannst beim TÜV wohl auch Umfragen und Auswertungen und sowas, kannst du beauftragen.
Fragt mich nicht genau, wie das heißt, aber man kann wohl zum TÜV gehen und sagen, hier, wir hätten gerne...
Man kann quasi den TÜV so als Art Berater irgendwie kaufen.
Zumindest hatten wir vom TÜV Leute da.
Die haben eine Mitarbeiterbefragung durchgeführt.
Und zwar eine Mitarbeiterbefragung zu, ja gut, letztendlich wie zufrieden oder was.
Was mögen die Leute, was mögen die Leute nicht.
So.
Da waren dann zum Beispiel so Fragen drin wie, wie klar sind Arbeitsaufträge definiert und solche Sachen.
Wie zufrieden sind sie mit ihrem Arbeitsplatz?
Also mit der Ausstattung an ihrem Arbeitsplatz und solche Geschichten.
So Fragen waren da drin.
Gut.
Und...
Diese Umfrage wurde gemacht.
Dann wurde das Ganze ausgewertet.
Dann kam aber...
Genau, dann gab es noch, dann gab es noch so eine Besprechung dazu.
Alles gut.
So und dann wurden die Ergebnisse vorgestellt.
Und jetzt kommt es, jetzt kommt es.
Dann wurde dann vorgestellt, okay.
Also, man würde ja normalerweise erwarten, es wird dann vorgestellt, bei diesem, in diesem Themenschwerpunkt, sagen wir jetzt zum Beispiel Ausstattung.
Am Arbeitsplatz.
Im Durchschnitt haben die Leute eine 3,7 vergeben.
Oder sowas.
Ja.
Das hätte man jetzt ja eigentlich erwartet, dass da sowas rauskommt.
3,7.
Klarheit der Aufgaben.
2,3.
Zufriedenheit mit Vorgesetzten.
1,8.
So nach dem Motto.
Das hätte man, hätte man jetzt erwarten können, dass da sowas in der Richtung rauskommt.
War es aber nicht.
Weil...
Wahrscheinlich ist ihnen bei der Auswertung aufgefallen, dass wir nicht so geil sind, wie erwartet.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, was kann man denn da machen?
Denn, man muss eine Sache wissen.
Dort, wo ich aktuell arbeite, ist es so.
Wir geben solche Sachen in Auftrag, weil wir denken, wir sind viel geiler, als wir sind.
Also, die erwarten, dass bei allen Sachen immer das Beste vom Besten rauskommt.
Und wenn es dann nicht so ist, dann sind sie, dann machen sie immer dieses surprised Pikachu-Face.
So, was?
Wie?
Doch nicht so geil.
Und dann muss überlegt werden, wie können wir das jetzt schön verkaufen.
So, und das war da auch wieder der Fall.
Die haben da nicht einfach vorgestellt, die Noten 1 zu 1, was rausgekommen ist.
Sondern, es gab nämlich ein paar Sachen, da waren wir richtig schlecht.
Da hatten wir 4,8 oder sowas.
Also, fast eine 5.
Also, richtig mies.
Das war unter anderem, glaube ich, bei Klarheit.
Wie klar sind die Aufgaben gestellt?
So, also.
Da kam die Präsentation.
Und was hat man gemacht?
Man hat nicht einfach die Noten vorgestellt.
In diesem Gebiet sind wir so, in diesem Gebiet so.
Nein.
Jetzt kommt der Hit.
Ich weiß noch, wie diese Ergebnispräsentation angefangen hat.
So nach dem Motto, ja, wir haben hier eine Umfrage gemacht.
Und was kam raus?
Wie zu erwarten, ein sehr gutes Ergebnis.
Und ich dachte mir schon so, wirklich?
Überall?
Also, entweder ist es überall komplett anders bei uns, als bei uns in dem Unternehmen.
Oder irgendwas ist sass.
So, und dann kam die Erklärung, wie sie das gemacht haben.
So, weil unsere Ergebnisse zu schlecht waren, um sie Standalone zu präsentieren, hat man folgendes gemacht.
Man hat sich einen Vergleichsdatensatz, einen anonymisierten Vergleichsdatensatz vom TÜV eingekauft.
Und hat quasi die Differenz dazu immer besonders hervorgehoben.
Oder halt, man hat immer besonders hervorgehoben, dass wir besser als der Vergleichsdatensatz sind.
Das Problem ist nur, wenn du schlecht bist.
Der TÜV hat ja sicherlich schon hunderte solcher Umfragen gemacht.
Wenn du schlecht bist.
Du wirst immer jemanden finden, der schlechter ist.
Den du dann als Vergleichsdatensatz nehmen kannst.
So nach dem Motto, du hast ne 4,8 in irgendeinem Gebiet.
Du findest sicherlich einen, der fast ne 6 hat.
Und dann kannst du sagen, im Vergleich, ein sehr gutes Ergebnis.
Das heißt im Endeffekt, die sind dann komplett darauf rumgeritten, wie geil sie dastehen versus den mega schlechten Vergleichsdatensatz.
Sodass man am Ende eigentlich den Eindruck hatte, wir sind die geilsten der geilsten.
Allerdings die Noten an sich.
Waren gar nicht mal sonderlich gut.
Das sind solche Sachen, wo ich mir immer denke, das geht mir bei dem Unternehmen mega auf den Sack.
So dieses, was gesagt wird, den Eindruck, den sie haben und was es wirklich ist.
Ein bisschen wie unbeschriftete Grafen.
Ja gut, das war bei mir tatsächlich das größte Problem.
Das habe ich auch gesagt bei diesem Interview jetzt wieder.
Dass es mir hauptsächlich um die Homeoffice Thematik ging.
Vor allem, weil man da so Rückzieher gemacht hat.
Jetzt unter dem Strich habe ich mehr Geld und mehr Homeoffice.
Und bestimmt die ein oder anderen Sachen, die mir nicht gefallen.
Das hast du aber überall.
Wie gut gehst du finanziell um?
Was?
Die Zusammenreihung an Wörtern ergeben keinen Sinn.
Meinst du, wie gut geht es dir finanziell?
Oder was?
Hä?
Das bringt mir jetzt nichts mehr in den Fragebögen.
Ist auch klar.
Ich würde gerne meine Haustürklingel smart machen.
Ich höre die Türklingel nicht im ganzen Haus.
Jetzt möchte ich, dass wenn jemand klingelt, dass eine Info auf das Handy kommt.
Hast du einen Tipp, wie man das lösen könnte?
Es kommt drauf an, was du für eine Klingel hast.
Es kommt auch drauf an, ob du in die Klingel dran darfst.
Ob du in der Miete wohnst oder nicht.
Das Allereinfachste ist, also was wirklich immer geht, ohne Eingriff in das Gerät.
Du nimmst ein ESP mit so einem Lautstärkesensor.
Was im Endeffekt einfach nur ein Mikrofon ist.
Was dann an einem digitalen Smartphone funktioniert.
Was dann an einem digitalen Pin ausgibt.
War über einer gewissen Lautstärke oder nicht.
Also du kannst ein ESP dranhängen oder auch in die Klingel reinmachen.
Der einfach ein Mikrofon hat und triggert, wenn das Mikrofon was wahrnimmt, was sehr laut ist.
Das kannst du machen.
Das geht immer und da brauchst du keinen Eingriff.
Ist vielleicht aber nicht die 100% zuverlässigste Variante.
Geht aber auf jeden Fall easy.
ESP32 mit einem Mikrofon bzw. Lautstärkesensor nennt sich es dann.
Aber unter der Haube ist es quasi ein ganz, ganz billiges Mikrofon.
Wo du quasi erkennst, wie laut was ist in der Nähe.
Das nimmt nichts auf, aber das guckt halt wie hoch ist der Input-Pegel.
Und dann triggert es einen Pin, wenn es über einem gewissen Level ist.
Ja, das ist das Einfachste.
Ansonsten, wenn du da an die Klingel dran kannst, gibt es natürlich noch viel, viel mehr Möglichkeiten.
Du kannst entweder einen Analog-zu-Digital-Converter dranmachen an dein ESP.
Und du misst irgendwie die Input-Spannung.
Falls irgendwie das Klingeln über die Input-Spannung auf den Leitungen signalisiert wird.
Du kannst alles mögliche machen.
Also das mit dem Mikrofon bzw. dem Lautstärkesensor ist dann mit Abstand das Einfachste.
Guck mal hier, Amazon.
Kannst es auch einfach.
ESP-Lautstärkesensor.
Noise.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was man da suchen muss.
So was, so was in der Richtung.
Hochempfindliches Mikrofon. Ja, ganz allerbeste.
So was in der Richtung brauchst du da.
Ja, das ist dann relativ easy.
Da kannst du dich einstellen.
Wann der Output-Pin triggert.
Und dann ist gut.
So was in der Richtung brauchst du an ESP.
Kosten beim ESP.
Du brauchst für das Projekt, brauchst du 5 Euro, wenn du es bei AliExpress kaufst.
Also die Message kannst du ja über alles mögliche machen lassen.
Also ich würde dir tatsächlich empfehlen, es nicht.
Also wenn du was an, wenn du noch ein bisschen mehr Automatisierung machen willst,
würde ich dir nicht unbedingt empfehlen, den ESP32 irgendwie direkt per Telegram oder so was schicken zu lassen.
Sondern du kannst, wenn du irgendeinen Smart Home-Hub hast, sei es Home Assistant,
Open Hub, was gibt es da noch hier?
Homey oder I.O. Broker oder so was.
Dann würde ich es darüber machen.
Dann würde ich vom ESP32 dahin schicken.
Hallo, ich habe ein Klingel-Signal erkannt.
Und dann würde ich meine Zentrale irgendeine Push-Notification zum Beispiel schicken lassen.
Also ich weiß, dass Home Assistant kann Push-Notification, wenn man die App installieren kann,
das Push-Notification auf alle Plattformen.
Und da brauchst du nichts über Telegram.
Einfach Push-Nachricht aufs Handy und gut ist.
Du kannst natürlich auch dein Handy klingeln.
Da kannst du auch die App installieren.
Das gibt nahezu unbegrenzte Möglichkeiten, wenn du es erstmal in deiner Smart Home-Zentrale drinnen hast.
Mit Geld um, wie gehst du um?
Achso, wie ich mit Geld umgehe?
Ich gebe einfach so gut wie nichts aus.
Ich habe einen ETF-Plan.
World Index, also was Idioten, was heißt sicher?
Sicher ist es ja nie, aber das Idiotensicherste, was es gibt, wenn es um ETFs geht.
Und ansonsten gebe ich kaum was aus.
Ich habe eigentlich nur immer größere Zahlen überall stehen, weil ich nichts ausgebe.
So gehe ich mit Geld um.
Ich gebe eigentlich so gut wie nichts aus.
Und das liegt gar nicht mal daran, weil ich nichts ausgeben will, weil ich mich so irgendwie absichtlich zurückhalte, nichts auszugeben.
Sondern weil ich mir, wenn ich was haben will, kaufe ich es mir halt und ansonsten gibt es wenig, was ich haben will.
Ganz einfach.
Ich kaufe mir halt ab und zu mal einen neuen Rechner oder sowas.
Ich habe letztens 5000 Euro für den Rechner ausgegeben, aber dafür das ganze Jahr sonst nichts.
Also insofern, wobei das stimmt nicht.
Letztes Jahr war teuer.
Neuer Rechner, neues Auto.
Letztes Jahr war wirklich teuer.
Das war aber wirklich mal was, was ähm, außergewöhnliches, das letzte Jahr.
Also so viel Geld wie letztes Jahr habe ich glaube ich noch nie ausgegeben.
Gibst du Geld für Urlaub aus?
Ich fahre eigentlich so gut wie nie in Urlaub.
Das ist schon eine ganze Weile her, wo ich zuletzt im Urlaub gewesen bin.
Boah, boah.
Da oben ist es viel zu hell.
Eine ganze Weile her.
Ich glaube das letzte Mal war ich auf Lanzarote im Urlaub.
Ist aber auch schon ein bisschen her.
Ja, und dann muss man natürlich Geld für ausgeben, weil, naja, das gibt es halt nicht umsonst.
Make your intercom smarter.
Ja, wie gesagt, gibt es 1000 Varianten, wie man das machen kann.
Gut, natürlich, man kann das auch anlöten, das funktioniert aber nicht bei allen.
Also bei dem hier mag das jetzt funktionieren.
Ja, da muss man sich halt genau angucken, was man da auch für ein Gerät hat.
Oh, guck mal, das ist gut.
Das ist ein Tiny Pico ESP32.
Ja, genau.
Davon habe ich auch noch ein paar.
Die Dinger sind wirklich gut, weil die sind ultra klein.
Kann man machen hier.
Wobei das schon ziemlich kacke aussieht.
Also je nachdem, ob und mit wem man zusammenwohnt, könnte das schon dazu führen, dass man das nicht machen darf.
Es gibt ja Leute, die haben so richtig Abneigung gegen Kabel.
Sobald man Kabel sieht, geht das nicht.
Ich habe da keine Schmerzen mit.
Hier sieht man überall Kabel, aber es gibt Leute, da ist das so.
Das ist übrigens der Auto, ach stimmt, der Name kam mir tatsächlich irgendwie bekannt vor.
Okay.
Pfeifhead-Typ.
Ich habe die Möglichkeit, das Haustelefon anzuzapfen.
Ja, da musst du nur gucken, ob es AC oder DC ist.
Und wie viel Spannung das ist.
Und dann kannst du das relativ gut abgreifen.
Wenn es AC ist, dann musst du da am besten mit irgendeinem Analog-zu-Digital-Converter dran und gucken, wie hoch ist die Spannung.
Weil das ja wahrscheinlich variiert.
Keine Ahnung, 25 Volt, wenn es klingelt, 12 oder was weiß ich.
Bei mir sind es 19 im Standby und sowas.
Ja, also du musst einfach den passenden Sensor suchen.
Je nachdem, wie du das machen willst.
Das einfachste ohne Eingriff ist natürlich das mit dem Mikrofon.
Ja.
So sieht es aus.
Leute, was gibt es denn auf Shithub diese Woche?
GitHub Trends.
Trending.
Was Trended wiegt?
Lass mich ran.
Krypto- und AI-Zeug.
AI-Zeug wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil.
API-Table.
API-Table-orientierte Low-Code-Plattform.
Mir ist jetzt immer noch ein Rätsel, warum das so angesagt ist.
Glauben die wirklich, dass irgendwelche Manager demnächst anfangen zu programmieren?
Okay.
Nein, das sieht optisch wenigstens ganz hübsch aus.
Welchen Passwort-Manager benutzt du?
Keepers.
Yes.
Deine Meinung zu Low-Code?
Ehrlich gesagt, außer ein bisschen ablästern drüber, ob Manager jetzt anfangen zu programmieren,
kann ich nicht, weil ich mich noch nicht wirklich im Detail damit auseinandergesetzt habe.
Hast du die Diskussion mitbekommen über diese Export-Funktion?
Ne, was?
Wo?
So, was trennt ihr noch?
DevOps-Exercises.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich ganz interessant.
Vielleicht können wir da mal die ein oder anderen Sachen machen.
DevOps-Exercises.
Warum nicht?
WeChat-Chat-GPT.
Was sonst?
Python.
Okay.
AI.
Notepad++.
Dass das mal trennt, hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Warum trennt denn das auf einmal auf Shithub?
Ach hier, das.
Ne, das habe ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Aber ich benutze ja auch nicht Keepers, diesen Key, sondern ich benutze ja auch.
Ich benutze ja Keepers.xc.
Und ich denke mal, das hat das Problem nicht.
Ist ja das Ding.
Chat-GPT.
Ein C++-Header-only-HTTP-HTTPS-Client-Library.
Geht die auf dem ESP32 und geht die mit HTTPS?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Oder doch?
Ne, wahrscheinlich nicht.
AI.
WinGet.
MonkaS.
AI.
Und Rust.
Selbstverständlich.
Was sonst?
Blazingly Fast.
Okay.
Die GitHub-Trends diese Woche waren nicht sonderlich spannend.
Hast du das am Handy?
Nö.
Handy.
Handy habe ich meine Passwörter nicht gesynct.
Ich sehe auch den Sinn dahinter nicht, die Passwörter ans Handy zu synct.
Okay.
Crap.
siempreanie.
Ja.
Gut.
Über backdrop- silly- booking.
Posten.
Ich muss sagen, ein paar Tenote muss man finden, auf der motivo Kati hierongeParty.
Des UV-Gears.
Ja, iz.
volt speichern wenn wenn man das will sich merken oder ein extra passwort safe
fürs handy machen ich würde ich würde nie meine kompletten passwörter überall
hin sinken einfach nur weil es geht man braucht man braucht sie ja zum
größten teil nicht wenn er sein laptop nicht mit hat dann soll er sich halt
daheim schon bei allen services einloggen dieser braucht oder aber er
wird wahrscheinlich im urlaub auch gar nicht brauchen auch wahrscheinlich am
handy im urlaub auch nicht mehr dann soll er als laptop mitnehmen wenn er es
braucht also keine ahnung gerade gerade ganz ehrlich gerade ins ausland je nach
dem woran fährt würde ich wahrscheinlich mein passwort safe erst recht nicht
mitnehmen je nachdem welches land du fährst natürlich also wenn jetzt da
wenn er nach spanien urlaub fährst würde ich mir da weniger gedanken machen
aber es gibt ja gibt ja durchaus länder wo ich mir das überlegen würde gibt ja
leute fahren zum beispiel nach ägypten oder so in urlaub da würde ich mir das
auch schon überlegen ob ich da wirklich mein passwort safe und alles mitnehmen
will
und weiß ja nie was da so abgeht also für das keine sinnvolle idee einfach
alles immer überall hin zu sinken ich will nächste woche nach finnland also
ganz ehrlich wenn ich aus dem haus gehe mit irgendwelchen daten würde ich
prinzipiell verschlüsseln nicht weil ich jetzt mir gedanken machen würde dass
der finnische geheimdienst oder so dein laptop konfisziert oder ausliest sondern
vielleicht verlierst du mal dein laptop oder die cloud einer den laptop oder
deine tasche mit dem laptop
gebt verloren oder was auch immer wenn hast du irgendwo eine kiste mit
sensiblen daten und verschlüsseln drauf liegen also das würde ich nicht machen
sobald der datenträger das haus verlässt spätestens dann muss auf verschlüsselt
werden am besten ist natürlich auch du als
prinzipiell alles bevor wichtige daten drauf kommen verschlüsselt weil dann
hast du später keinerlei probleme mehr wenn du den rechner verkaufen willst oder
wegwerfen will es oder sonst was das wieder runter zu kommen du musst
das poker zu stellen
Und normalerweise dir überlegen, zum Beispiel, ich habe hier hinter mir noch den alten Rechner stehen, den ich jetzt hier ausgetauscht habe.
Also das ist noch die Xeon-Kiste, den vorletzten Rechner stehen.
Der hat eine SSD drin, eine Festplatte drin, hat alles verschlüsselt.
Das heißt, jetzt könnte ich das Ding 1 zu 1, wenn ich das machen würde, so auf Ebay setzen und verkaufen, ohne dass ich erstmal booten müsste und überlegen, wie mache ich denn ein Secure Erase von meiner SSD.
Was manchmal gar nicht so einfach ist.
Eine Festplatte ist einfach zu löschen. Eine Festplatte überschreibst du einfach mit Nullen.
Es muss noch nicht mal random sein, Nullen reicht.
Du kannst einfach die Festplatte überschreiben und gut ist.
Bei SSDs ist es nicht so einfach.
Erstens ist SSD komplett überschreiben eh keine allzu schlaue Idee, weil das meistens das interne, wie heißt das, Haltbarkeits-Dingsbums triggert.
Am besten ist, du machst...
Oder man macht ein Secure Erase von der SSD und das ist halt je nach SSD und Hersteller immer ein bisschen anders, sodass quasi die SSD, das ist so was wie in den Werkszustand zurücksetzen, die SSD.
Das muss man machen, muss man sich das erstmal angucken, aber wenn die SSD verschlüsselt ist, ich könnte das Ding jetzt 1 zu 1 so auf Ebay-Stellen verkaufen und ich müsste mir keine Gedanken machen.
Oder ich könnte auch einfach das Ding auf die Müllhalde schmeißen und muss mir keine Gedanken machen, dass vielleicht noch einer die SSD ausbaut und benutzt.
Also deswegen.
Aber gut, wenn der Kram verschlüsselt ist.
Zumal man auch durch Verschlüsselung nahezu keine Performance-Einbußen mehr hat.
Ich meine ernsthaft, ich habe hier eine SSD drin, die macht was, 4500 MB die Sekunde, super schnelle CPU mit Hardware, AES, Encryption, Decryption, du merkst quasi keinerlei Leistungseinbußen da drauf.
Und warum sollte man es nicht verschlüsseln?
Du bist was, Systemanalytiker?
Oh, das klingt äußerst Sixheader.
Wie schwer kann man das Passwort beim Einloggen?
Von Ubuntu umgehen?
Wenn die Festplatte nicht verschlüsselt, dann easy, gar nichts.
Also das einfachste bei sowas ist gar nicht das Passwort zu umgehen, sondern die Festplatte einfach auszubauen oder mit einem USB-Stick zu booten.
Und dann an die Festplatte dranzugehen, dann muss man sich mit dem Passwort gar nicht mehr auseinandersetzen.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen, ist es nicht so einfach.
Du kannst in den, du kannst in deinen, kannst den Crab, wenn du Crab verwendest, du kannst in den Crab gehen und machst dann sowas wie...
Init gleich bin SH oder Init 1 oder sowas, je nachdem, ob es ein Ubuntu oder ein Red Hat ist.
Wahrscheinlich steht hier sowas ähnliches drinne.
Was kannst du machen?
Ja, du kannst, du kannst, also wenn du Zugriff auf einen Bootmanager hast, kannst du in der Regel direkt als Root booten.
Das kann man umgehen, aber das Beste ist, das Einfachste, was du machen kannst, ist schlicht und ergreifend einfach deine Festplatte verschlüsseln.
Weil dann startet der Rechner gar nicht, ohne dass du das Passwort eingibst.
Doch, das ist easy, das ist easy.
Und das ist aber so das Allereinfachste.
Nur, dass du was wissen musst, ist tatsächlich vom USB-Stick zu booten.
Das Passwort ist nutzlos.
Ja, das Passwort ist nur nicht nutzlos.
Es gibt ja noch die Möglichkeit, dass du mit dem Passwort dein Heimatverzeichnis verschlüsselst.
Ich glaube, Ubuntu hat zwei verschiedene Verschlüsselungsvarianten während der Installation.
Du kannst auswählen.
Ich möchte, dass ich das komplette System verschlüsseln.
Da musst du beim Boot ein Passwort eingeben.
Und ich glaube, es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, dass man nur das Heimatverzeichnis verschlüsselt.
Das, dann wird das Passwort benutzt vom Login.
Dann kannst du, dann kannst du sowas machen.
Du kannst es auch nicht einfach umgehen ohne das Passwort.
Dann kannst du es zwar mit dem USB-Stick starten oder mit Root-Shell starten.
Aber du kannst die Daten nicht lesen.
So, das ist natürlich ganz nützlich, wenn du zum Beispiel ein System hast, was mehrere Leute verwenden.
Und du nicht willst, dass du ein Passwort für alles hast.
Es kommt selten vor.
Ja, ja.
Deswegen, wenn man sich Gedanken machen muss.
Also, ich würde prinzipiell wahrscheinlich gar nicht in solche Länder fahren, wo man sich da Gedanken machen muss.
Aber, wenn man sich da Gedanken machen muss, ist tatsächlich auch möglich, dass man zum Beispiel Let's Encrypt.
Nicht Let's Encrypt.
Was?
Veracrypt.
Nicht Let's Encrypt.
Dass man so Sachen wie Veracrypt verwendet.
Und eine öffentliche Windows-Installation hat und eine verschlüsselte Windows-Partition.
Wo man allerdings nicht erkennt, dass es eine verschlüsselte Windows-Partition ist.
Also, du kannst den Laptop ganz normal booten.
Sieht dann aus wie ein ganz normales Laptop.
Ganz normal Windows.
So drauf.
Aber du hast dann noch ein zweites verschlüsseltes Windows drauf.
Das heißt, du kannst, wenn dich dann irgendjemand fragt.
Das steht auch bei Veracrypt schön beschrieben auf der Seite.
Du kannst dann quasi, wenn du am Flughafen, wenn du nach Nordkorea fliegst.
Und am Flughafen sagen sie dir, es reicht ja schon, wenn du in die USA fliegst.
Und du sollst dein Laptop aufmachen.
Dann machst du dein Laptop auf und sagst, hier guckt euch alles an.
Und da ist natürlich nichts drauf.
Aber von dem verschlüsselten System kriegen sie hoffentlich nichts mit.
Gibt es zig Varianten.
Ja.
Aber ganz im Ernst, wenn ihr irgendwo in Urlaub fahrt.
Da würde ich jetzt wenig, also gerade wenn ihr irgendwie in der EU unterwegs seid.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel nach Finnland oder so fliegt.
Da würde ich mir weniger Gedanken drüber machen, dass ihr wirklich irgendwelche Leute wollen, dass ihr euren Laptop entschlüsselt und so.
Sondern würde ich mir eher Gedanken drüber machen, was passiert, wenn euch der Laptop geklaut wird.
Wenn die Tasche verloren geht.
Oder ihr das Ding mal irgendwo liegen lasst.
Was auch immer.
Dass das Ding abhanden kommt.
Also deswegen.
Sobald.
Der Datenträger die eigenen vier Wände verlässt.
Spätestens dann sollte er verschlüsselt sein.
Das gilt übrigens auch für USB-Sticks.
Wenn da was wichtiges drauf ist.
Wenn natürlich da, wenn der USB-Stick leer ist.
Und ihr da einfach nur.
Irgendwie.
Keine Ahnung.
Zu irgendeinem Kollege wollt und ein paar Fotos kopieren.
Da könnt ihr euch das mit Verschlüsseln sparen.
Wenn das keine relevanten, wichtigen Fotos sind.
Aber sobald da irgendwas wichtiges drauf ist.
Und die eigenen vier Wände verlässt.
Spätestens dann verschlüsseln.
Und wie gesagt.
Ansonsten einfach direkt die Sachen verschlüsseln.
Dann hat man viel weniger, viel weniger Schmerzen.
Wie funktioniert das unter Windows?
Was das System ist.
Veracrypt verwenden.
Easy.
Das da.
Einzige französische Software, die ich glaube ich verwende.
Veracrypt.
Beste für Windows.
Und nicht BitLocker.
Das ist der Nachfolger von TrueCrypt.
Ja, da musst du dir schon was.
Du solltest dir schon was überlegen, dass es dann glaubwürdig aussieht.
Dein Fake Windows.
Also nicht eine frische Windows-Installation.
Ohne was drauf.
VLC ist auch französisch.
Ja, aber VLC.
VLC wissen wir alle.
VLC ist böse.
Wisst ihr auch noch, warum VLC böse ist?
Kann sich da noch jemand dran erinnern?
Hat das keiner von euch mitgekriegt, ja?
Na, VLC ist böse, weil es so eine Weihnachtsmann-Mütze drin hat.
Das Hütchen, genau.
Ja.
VLC.
Centerhead.
Ne, nicht so.
Und da gibt's jedes Mal, da gibt's jedes Mal Diskussionen, da gibt's jedes Mal nervige
Diskussionen, warum das ein Weihnachts-, ein Weihnachtsmann-Hütchen hat.
DLCs sind auch böse.
Ja, so ein Buchstabenunterschied.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, als die Leute gedrängert waren, weil Visual Studio
Code auch so eine Mütze hatte?
Wo sie danach, wo sie danach eine Snowflake reingemacht haben, was wahrscheinlich noch
mehr Leute gedrängert hat.
Die haben echt alle große Probleme.
Und ich wette mit euch, mittlerweile viele von diesen ich-bin-super-gedriggert-Posts sind
gar nicht Leute, die gedriggert sind, sondern Leute, die gedrollt gedriggert sind, die sich
denken, okay, ich spring da jetzt mal drauf auf, um die abzufacken.
Ja.
Und dann hat er damals auch diesen Chatbot von Microsoft trainiert, der dann irgendwie,
irgendwie Nazi-Zeug von sich gegeben hat nach, nach zwei Tagen.
Ist aber schon, ist, ist schon ein paar Jahre her.
Ist quasi, quasi so der, der Vor-, Vor-, Vorgänger von Chat-GPT.
Microsoft hatte mal nen Twitter-, hatte mal, hatte mal versucht, nen Twitter-Bot zu veröffentlichen
und die haben einen.
Was heißt versucht?
Die haben einen Twitter-Bot veröffentlicht.
Weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das Ding hieß.
Zumindest.
Die haben nen, die haben nen Twitter-Bot veröffentlicht bei Microsoft, der eben halt auf alles Mögliche
antworten sollte und die Leute haben den dann zugespampt mit irgendwelchen rechten Sachen,
ja, mit irgendwelchen Nazi-Sprüchen und sonst was.
Und, ähm, wenn dann, das hat sogar, glaube ich, nur ein paar Stunden gedauert und nach
ein paar Stunden, wenn man den Bot, wenn man den Bot auf Twitter was gefragt hat, hat er
dann irgendwelche Nazi-Sprüche von sich gegeben.
Das war richtiger Fail, das Ding.
Das haben sie dann auch, das haben sie dann auch wieder abgeschaltet nach zwei Tagen.
Das ging, das, das ging auf jeden Fall in die Hose, der Versuch, ja.
Tay hieß das Ding, genau.
Genau hier, hier gibt's da, gibt's sogar noch nen Artikel zu.
Das ist schon 2016, Leute, schon sechs Jahre her.
Hier.
Twitter taught Microsoft's AI Chatbot to be a racist asshole in less than a day.
So.
Guck, solche Antworten kamen dann da drauf.
Solche Antworten hat dann dieser Chatbot gegeben.
Ich mach's jetzt nicht in groß.
Das ist ja schon fast an der Grenze von drei.
Ja.
So, Toss, ja.
Solche, solche Sachen hat dann der, hat dann der Chatbot geantwortet.
Also, das ging in die Hose, der Versuch.
Microsoft bildet wohl ChatGPT in Teams und Bing.
Ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Ich mein, ich hab ChatGPT auf meine Shell eingebunden mittlerweile.
Warum nicht auch in Teams und Bing?
So, wir gucken uns jetzt mal an, was wir heute gucken können.
Wisst ihr eine Sache, wo mich ChatGPT wirklich nervt?
Hm.
Und was in Zukunft noch zunehmen wird?
Und wo's schwierig sein wird, was zugegen machen?
Auf Reddit und in Foren gibt es mittlerweile sicherlich auch Stackoverflow, wobei da seh ich selten, weil die Leute halt die Sachen ab und down voten eventuell.
Aber ich seh's in Foren total oft, dass mittlerweile ChatGPT-Antworten kommen.
Zum Beispiel, es war am Anfang, als das aufgekommen ist im Home Assistant Forum, wie die Pest.
Da war gefühlt jede zweite Antwort von ChatGPT.
Die Leute machen sich dann einen Account und haben einen Account, geben die Frage in ChatGPT ein und pasten dann die Antwort.
Und pasten dann die Antwort von ChatGPT als Antwort in ein Diskussionsforum.
Richtig dumm.
Vor allem bringen die Antworten meistens gar nix.
In die Mediathek kannst du nicht gucken.
Nee, eher nicht.
Ich bezahl zwar Gebühren, aber ich darf selbstverständlich nichts mit dem Content machen.
Das ist ja logisch.
Kann ja nicht sein.
Also, wir bezahlen alle Gebühren, aber wir dürfen damit nichts nicht machen.
Also, ich hab auch nen ChatGPT-Rapper fürs Terminal.
Kann ich jetzt ChatGPT eingeben und die Frage dahinter.
Und wenn ChatGPT greift, kann ich das auch machen.
Und wenn ChatGPT gerade nicht überlastet ist, dann funktioniert es auch.
Es ist tatsächlich für Shell-Kommandos gar nicht übel.
Also, gerade zum Erklären von Shell-Kommandos ist ChatGPT erstaunlich gut.
Wenn man ChatGPT zum Beispiel fragt, so was bedeutet rsync-a-v-info gleich progress2.
Rapper selbst geschrieben, nee.
Fertig von GitHub.
Den ersten, den wir hier haben.
Den ersten, den man findet.
Soll es nicht auch Premium-ChatGPT gibt es?
Da musst du...
Hab ich ja.
Also, ich hab ja zwei Sachen.
Guck mal.
Schau mal, ob's jetzt funktioniert.
Ich hab ja zwei Sachen bei mir in der VM.
Einmal...
Joa, es lädt aber langsam jetzt.
Auf, auf.
Warp-Terminal ist bei mir unten durch.
Ich seh nicht ein, dass ich bei dem Terminal nen Login brauche.
Also, ich mein, seriously.
Ich mach mir doch keinen Account, dass ich mein Terminal verwenden kann.
So, also, ich kann zum Beispiel einmal ChatGPT fragen.
So, also, ich mach mir doch keinen Account, dass ich mein Terminal verwenden kann.
So, nach dem Motto Omega-Lul.
Und dann hoffen, dass es funktioniert.
ChatGPT klappt auch nicht.
Oder ich kann Github...
Alter, okay, meine Session ist wieder abgelaufen.
Ja, oder, oder ich kann ChatGPT...
Äh, ich kann Github-CodePilot zum Beispiel fragen.
So, R-Sync-V-A.
Der Unterschied ist, dass ich meine Session wieder abgelaufen habe, weil ich noch nicht
die Session abgelaufen habe.
Ja, oder, oder ich kann ChatGPT, äh, ich kann Github-CodePilot zum Beispiel fragen.
So, R-Sync-V-A.
Der Unterschied ist, dass ich meine Session wieder abgelaufen habe, weil ich noch nicht
die Session abgelaufen habe.
Ja, oder, oder ich kann ChatGPT...
Äh, ich kann Github-CodePilot zum Beispiel fragen.
So, R-Sync-V-A.
Der Unterschied ist...
Jaja.
Wobei, wobei, R-Sync-V-A kann ich nicht fragen.
Ich kann eher fragen, so, how to sync files between server on Linux.
Irgendwie so was kann ich fragen.
So.
Ja, das ist gut.
oder sagt der erste minus blablabla ok also das hier unten ist github code
pilot das oben ist chat gpt aber chat gpt muss ich mich jetzt erstmal wieder
einloggen dass die session läuft der unterschied ist dass da unten ist ein
premium service über die api das kostet geld
wobei es aktuell nicht wirklich geld kostet weil man 18 18 dollar startguthaben
bekommt es noch beta ist aber die request sind nicht billig also du
bezahlst bis zu 12 cent pro anfrage ja viel viel zu teuer eigentlich um
das täglich mehrfach zu verwenden und das hier oben benutzt die browser
session das heißt das ist kostenlos hat aber auch seine probleme
premium ist immer also die die premium war ja ist halt immer schnell und auch
immer verfügbar aber die kostet was und ist gar nicht also die die die open api
die ist nicht billig die ist wirklich nicht nicht nicht nicht im günstigen
anzusiedeln
ja guck mal pricing ach guck mal hier hast du schon mal hier bist du schon bei
fast 1 bis 2 cent pro image ihr bist du für anfragen bei ungefähr ungefähr 2
cent tokens sind quasi so art wörter und es geht jetzt dort nicht also es geht
nicht unbedingt um die anfrage die du sendest also soweit ich weiß bezieht
sich das auch folgendes die preise hier
also tokens sind wörter allerdings nicht die wörter die man da anfragt also
wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel an chat gpt über die api fragen würde erklär mir
dieses linux kommando rsync-va das sind nicht die tokens die zählen die
tokens die zählen ist deine anfrage plus der prompt der den bot konfiguriert
also der prompt ist das wo drinnen steht wie sich der bot verhalten soll so nach
dem motto du bist ein linux terminal und bla bla bla
du bist ein linux terminal und bla bla bla
bla bla bla also der prompt plus ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher aber
ich glaube das ist der prompt plus deine anfrage zählt und so ein prompt ist ja
auch schon ein bisschen länger das heißt du bist du bist dann relativ schnell hier
auch mal bei bei zwei cent pro anfrage und das ist schon ein bisschen was also
billig ist es tatsächlich nicht chat gpt selber nicht aber du kannst die
models hinter chat gpt über die api fragen was wahrscheinlich so ziemlich
ziemlich auf ähnliche sachen rauskommt also das hier ist der
äh
Wir hatten das
also kidnager gibt es schon über die api das nennt sich dann codecs genau codecs
ist
codecs ist das was sich unter unter co
co co pilot und da ist das ist codecs und die langwegehöre des ganzen f похab fragend
also
dass das geht auf jeden fall in die richtung und das ist nicht billig also das tatsächlich
wenn man das öfter benutzen will dich billig
Wenn man gar einen eigenen Service damit bauen will, dann musst du das quasi kostenpflichtig machen, sonst kannst du es nicht betreiben.
Bist du Max FPS von früher?
Nein, bin ich nicht.
Ich bin Wobblos.
Darf man die Antworten dann kommerziell nutzen?
Ja.
Wenn du die API benutzt?
Offiziell, sicherlich.
Aber davon abgesehen, jeder benutzt Chat-GPT kommerziell, der YouTube-Videos drüber macht.
Auf einer Skala von 0 bis gar kein Bock, wie ist deine Motivation auf deinen letzten Wochen im Job?
Okay, Leute, ich will nicht lügen, meine Motivation ist kaum vorhanden.
Also ich übergebe noch ein paar Sachen und ansonsten, ehrlich gesagt, hält es sich sehr, sehr in Grenzen.
Nö, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Keine Ahnung.
Habe ich nicht gelesen.
Chat-GPT Plus gibt es.
Aha.
Ja, siehst du?
Das ist jetzt ganz neu.
Boah, Alter, ich bin so...
Das ist zu hell, die Seite.
Ja, was sollst du auch machen?
Ich muss ja nichts mehr interessieren.
Das kann ja alles...
Ich muss ja nicht am Arsch vorbeigehen.
Du kannst das alles mit gewissem Abstand beobachten und dir denken, wen juckt's?
Okay, lasst uns mal.
Was ist das?
23, das haben wir schon geguckt.
Lasst uns mal ein bisschen Zeug anschauen.
Was können wir uns dann angucken?
Lohnt es sich, Software-Entwickler zu sein?
Kommt sicherlich drauf an.
Braunkohle-Bagger-Bergwerk.
Das verdient ein Schichtleiter im Tagebau.
Alter, okay, das interessiert mich tatsächlich, weil eigentlich müssten die Leute richtig, richtig fetten Zuschlag bekommen.
Wer will so einen Scheiß schon machen?
Mal davon abgesehen, ist es ja auch kein Beruf jetzt mit sonderlich Zukunft, weil allzu lang wird es das nicht mehr geben.
0,1 MS Gaming Monitor.
Eddie, das Ding will ich mir kaufen.
Deswegen muss ich mir das Video angucken, ob das was traugt.
Das Ding will ich mir kaufen.
Aber ich will noch abwarten, ob es nicht dieses Jahr von mehr Herstellern...
...so was in der Richtung gibt.
Komm, wir gucken uns mal an.
Das interessiert mich tatsächlich jetzt.
Deswegen fangen wir damit mal an.
Das interessiert mich tatsächlich jetzt, was ein Bergarbeiter, Bergbau-Dingsarbeiter, Braunkohle-Bauarbeiter verdient.
Also ich würde tatsächlich vermuten, also ich würde es hoffen, dass der mehr bekommt als ich.
Allein schon, weil es gefährlich ist.
Und weil es auch äußerst nervige Arbeitsbedingungen sind.
Also wer sowas...
...freiwillig machen will, sollte das ordentlich bezahlt kriegen.
Und es hat ja wenig Zukunft.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Interessiert mich tatsächlich.
Mal ausnahmsweise.
Ups, bis jetzt bin ich zu lang.
Es kann auch um Leben und Tod gehen.
Ich muss dich bitten, hier stehen zu bleiben, ja?
Es kann nass werden.
Es kann dreckig sein.
Man sollte auf jeden Fall auch schwindelfrei sein.
Ich bin zufrieden mit meinem Gehalt, ja.
Die Augen können manchmal groß werden.
Jedes Mal wieder, wenn ich in das große Loch reingucke, ist es für mich eine absolute Faszination.
Hi, mein Name ist Mehdi Zawali.
Ich bin 27 Jahre alt, komme aus Köln und bin Schichtleiter bei RWE im Tagebau Hambach.
Und heute nehme ich euch für einen Tag mit.
Hi, grüß dich.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
In der Regel bereite ich mein Essen für zwei bis drei Tage vor.
Und dadurch, dass ich halt wenig aushause esse, reduziert das das Ganze auch wieder.
Gibt's da eigentlich...
...wird da eigentlich Essen geliefert?
Ja.
Wird da Essen geliefert in den Berg rein, oder...?
Das haben wir schon mal.
In der Regel arbeite ich sieben Spätschichten am Stück durch.
Darauf folgen sieben Nachtschichten, also 14 Tage am Stück.
Boah, das ist ja abfuck, Alter.
Und hab dann nach den zwei Wochen...
Okay, es ist lebensgefährlich, sind scheiß Arbeitsbedingungen und es ist Schichtarbeit.
Das muss gut bezahlt werden, sonst macht es doch keiner.
Sieben Tage freier.
Dankeschön für vier Milliarden Subs.
Äh, Bits, Bits, Netwalker.
Ich hab den für sehr wenig Geld gekauft, der hat doch schon ein paar Kilometer gebraucht.
Für sehr wenig Geld, der hat bloß 40.000 Euro ausgegeben.
Aber bringt mir sicher von A nach B.
Den Luxus nehme ich mir schon heraus, mit dem Auto zur Arbeit zu fahren.
Wobei, das ist ein bisschen älterer BMW gewesen, das geht schon.
... ein großes Loch, in dem viele Erdschichten abgetragen werden, um an die in der Tiefe liegende Kohle dranzukommen.
Wir fördern Kohle, um damit Energie zu erzeugen.
Natürlich haben wir der Natur was genommen, aber wir wollen das doppelt tun.
Am besten das Dreifache wieder zurückgeben.
Ja, ihr wollt vielleicht, aber so wird das nicht funktionieren.
Ich meine, wie lange hat das gedauert, bis sich die Kohle da gebildet hat?
Keine Ahnung, 800 Millionen Jahre oder so?
Ein paar Bäume pflanzen wird es jetzt da nicht wirklich rausreißen.
Kohle abgetragen wird, die verschütten wir bei uns wieder und erschaffen eine neue Landschaft.
Ja, und jetzt mag ich mich nackig, ne?
Gatschi-Bus-Time.
Tada! Wunderbar. Mahlzeit, Kollegen.
Noch nachts.
Okay, 12 vor 30 ist dann quasi Spätschicht.
Die Rampe wird später zwingend notwendig sein, damit Autos, Hilfsgeräte dort über die Rampe hoch und über die Kohle fahren können.
Und ich sag mal, wenn da die Rampe nicht so sitzt, wie sie sein sollte, könnte das erstmal zu einem längeren Stau führen.
Und das wäre absolut nicht von Vorteil.
Den Einsatz, wo wir uns heute auch dran geben werden, ist kein ganz normaler Einsatz.
Also das wird da schon ein bisschen Fingerspitzengefühl brauchen und einen erfahrenen und guten Mitarbeiter, der das Ganze da vernünftig verkippt.
Auf geht's.
Der kippt.
Die Kollegen warten.
Jetzt geht's rüber in den Einteilungsraum, wo die Mannschaft wartet, praktisch ihre Aufgaben zugeteilt zu bekommen.
Und jetzt ist halt die Kommunikation das Entscheidende.
Um genau die Informationen, die ich ja eben bekommen habe, auch so wiederzugeben, dass die Arbeit dann vernünftig ausgeführt werden kann.
Da kann man nur hoffen, dass dort der Informationsfluss von demjenigen, der sich das ausdenkt, zu denjenigen, die es machen müssen, besser funktioniert als bei uns.
Weil sonst hätten die ein paar Probleme.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dort geht es ja wirklich extrem um Leben und Tod, dass es gut funktioniert.
Das heißt, dort wird es wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren.
Jetzt.
Ich bin als Schichtleiter Vorgesetzter von circa 20 Mitarbeitern.
Also die Kollegen, für die ich zuständig bin, haben eine Berufserfahrung von 35 Jahren.
Das bedeutet, deren Berufserfahrung ist weit älter, als wie ich überhaupt alt bin.
Schön, wieder hier zu sein.
Ja.
Was denn?
Grau.
Bei mir die Haare.
Ja, das ist ihr.
Ihr stresst mich zu sehr.
Man verbringt sehr viel Zeit mit den Kollegen.
Über Jahre.
Und das ist eigentlich mehr eine große Familie.
In der Familie kann man sich in der Regel auch auf jeden verlassen.
Und so ist es auf der Arbeit auch.
Deswegen sagen wir lieber, wir sind Kumpels.
Morat, mit dir stand das Sicherheits-Kurzgespräch noch aus, was wir für diesen Monat machen.
Das Thema diesen Monat ist Berühren und Überfahren werden von Hilfsgeräten.
Überfahren werden?
Kommt das da regelmäßig vor?
Ja, haltend Stopp vor Start.
Es könnte passieren, dass man überfahren wird.
Maschinen, in die man eingezogen werden kann.
Das ist aber schlecht, wenn man überfahren wird.
Also es kann auch mal gefährlich werden.
Im schlimmsten Fall geht es um Leben und Tod.
Hier ist ja die alte Rampe, wo ich gestern die PE-Leitungen habe wegziehen lassen.
Hinter der Rampe fangen wir eine neue Rampe an zu kippen, ja?
Ja.
Alles klar.
Machen wir uns auf den Weg.
Und auch mein Helm darf nicht fehlen.
Wir fahren jetzt direkt tatsächlich ins Tagebau-Tiefste, wo die Kohle auch gefördert wird.
Man kann meistens überfahren.
Wir sind wirklich da, wo das Material fällt.
Am besten erkennen, wie die Materialzusammensetzung ist.
Und um mich da nochmal zu vergewissern, schaue ich mir das Ganze von oben an.
Alter, was ein riesen Teil, Mann.
Guckt euch das Ding mal an, Mann.
Das ist, das ist, das ist mein Haus mal, keine Ahnung, 20 oder so.
Das Ding ist ja mega fett.
Man sollte auf jeden Fall auch schwindelfrei sein.
Das passt.
Man erkennt, dass das Material kein Wasser in sich trägt, also sehr trocken ist.
Ist das, ist das Kohle, was da rauskommt, oder was ist das?
Material.
Kein Wasser in sich trägt.
Das ist Kohle.
Und das wird jetzt auf den Berg geschüttet?
Auf einen Haufen geschüttet?
Und dann?
Dann, dann wird es abtransportiert, oder wie, mit, mit, mit Lastern, oder wie klappt das?
Ich habe keine Ahnung davon.
Das passt.
Man erkennt, dass das Material kein Wasser in sich trägt, also sehr trocken ist und
eignet sich damit für uns, um eine tragfähige Stützrüppe zu bauen.
Eine Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung ist auf jeden Fall sehr wichtig, gerade bei einem
Job wie meinem.
Deswegen sollte ich mich da eventuell bald möglichst drum kümmern.
Ich schiebe es immer wieder auf, aber, ja, steht auf.
Ja, da kann dir relativ schnell mal was auf Fuß, aufs Bein, auf den Kopf, wie auch immer,
fallen.
Ja, ich habe euch, ich habe euch ja schon die Story erzählt von meinem Mit-Azubi damals,
der früher Steinmetz war und jetzt Fachinformatiker.
Dem ist auch was auf den Fuß gefallen.
Seitdem kann er nicht mehr Steinmetz sein.
Und jetzt ist er Fachinformatiker und ist überhaupt nicht seins.
Ich gehe mal oben schauen, wie es aussieht.
Die Kollegen haben jetzt eine Wasserverbindung angeschlossen und mit Feuerwehrschleuschen
und hohem Druck an Wasser versuchen wir, den Schlamm aus den Bändern, aus den Gurten
rauszureinigen, damit wir dann schnellstmöglichst wieder ans Laufen kommen.
Jetzt volle Pulle.
Marcel, lass laufen!
Gachi-Bars wegspritzen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht der Optimalfall.
Der war jung, der war jünger als ich damals.
Ich muss dich bitten, hier stehen zu bleiben, ja?
Boah!
Alter!
Ich hoffe jetzt erstmal, dass wir wieder laufen können, ne?
Da können wir aber auch jetzt wieder laufen.
Ja.
Man kann schon mal dreckig werden, ja?
Also es bleibt nicht aus, dass man auch zwischendurch mal die Klamotten ein bisschen versaut hat.
Nur wenn es jetzt regnet oder schneit oder friert, heißt das nicht, dass wir die Arbeit
einstellen.
Die Arbeit geht weiter.
Und die Kollegen draußen vor Ort an den Geräten stehen wieder da.
Stehen bei Wind und Wetter draußen vor Ort.
Da sieht man aber wieder den Unterschied zwischen so jemand oder dieser Excel-Maus-Schubserin,
die wir da auch mal in irgendeinem Video hatten.
Der, ja, war Unternehmensberaterin, die den ganzen Tag nur Excel gemacht hat.
Ich mein, der Typ ist fertig, wenn der heimkommt, ja?
Der kommt heim und er will wahrscheinlich nur noch pennen.
Und dann geht's morgen weiter.
14 Tage am Stück.
Nachts auch noch.
Wir nehmen in regelmäßigen Abständen Bodenproben.
Die dienen dazu, um nachzuweisen, dass wir genug fruchtbaren Boden aufgeschüttet haben,
um die landwirtschaftliche und forstwirtschaftliche Rekultivierung auch gewährleisten zu können.
Hier entsteht nur noch Wald.
Und umso wichtiger ist es da, die langfristige Planung einzuhalten und die genauen Höhen.
Die vorgegebene Sollhöhe haben wir auf jeden Fall eingehalten.
Wir liegen bei 251,5 Meter.
Und das passt definitiv.
Mission erledigt.
Wir haben einen guten Job gemacht.
Ist der von ganz unten da hochgelaufen?
Leute, ich kann euch als eigene Erfahrung sagen, 200 Meter gerade den Berg hoch ist nicht so ohne.
250 Meter gerade den Berg hoch.
Also je nachdem, wie steil das ist, ist das schon recht anstrengend.
Okay, jetzt zeigt mal der Spieler.
Jetzt bin ich wirklich mal gespannt, was er verdient.
Toss, Toss.
Mahlzeit, Füße vom Tisch.
Es gibt Tage, wo man ein bisschen mehr Zeit hat für die Pause.
Und Tage wie heute, wo man das Ganze dann zwischendurch macht.
18.30 Uhr, da habe ich schon seit vorneweg zweieinhalb Stunden Feierabend.
Dann haben wir noch einen Ablösebericht, in dem wir den aktuellen Stand praktisch nochmal dokumentieren.
Ich habe mein reines Grundgehalt, aber den wesentlichen Teil machen meine Zulagen aus.
Ja, das dachte ich mir.
Wir kriegen eine Nachtschichtzulage.
Gefahrenzulage und alles Mögliche.
Und Sonntage und Feiertage werden auch zusätzlich und extra bezahlt.
Ein guter Beispielmonat wäre ca. 7100 Euro.
7100 Euro brutto.
Und dann bleiben einem 4...
Ja, das geht doch.
1500 Euro netto.
Ich spare viel.
Viele Rücklagen.
Auch eine schöne Altersfrage.
Da geht doch was.
Ganz ehrlich, das ist ein scheiß Job.
Das ist gefährlich.
Es ist Schichtarbeit nachts.
Das ist nur gerechtfertigt, dass der Kerl so viel kriegt.
Ich kaufe viele Aktien.
Zwischendurch auch ein bisschen Krypto, Bitcoin, Ethereum.
Dann bis Dienstag.
Danke.
Ruhige Schicht.
Das ist tatsächlich ungefähr,
UNGEFÄHR
so viel, wie ich mit 5 Tagen im neuen Job verdienen würde.
UNGEFÄHR.
Also bei mir sind...
Ich habe es euch ja erzählt im Video.
Bei mir schwankt es ein bisschen.
Je nachdem, wie viel Bonuszahlung das ist.
Das kann so von 95k bis 115k gehen.
Realistisch wird es wahrscheinlich ungefähr,
ungefähr in dem Bereich liegen, was er auch hat.
Nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass er sich teilweise in Lebensgefahr begibt
und ich vor dem Rechner hocke.
Das stimmt.
Er hat sicherlich mehr übrig am Ende,
weil die ganzen Zulagen anders besteuert werden.
Ich kenne das von unserem Support.
Der hat auch Nachtzulage, Feiertagszulage, Schichtzulage und alles mögliche.
Und das wird auch anders oder teils gar nicht besteuert.
Deswegen wisst ihr, dass bei uns im Support,
ich nenne es mal Support,
was da total beliebt ist,
sind Feiertage, Feiertage und in Kombination Feiertage, Wochenende
oder am besten ist Feiertage, Wochenende, Weihnachten und sowas.
Da gibt es dann irgendwie 200% Zulage und so Zeug.
Da reißen die sich alle drum.
Man würde eigentlich denken, die Leute wollen eher daheim bleiben.
Bei Weihnachten aber ne, ne.
Die wollen quasi für 7 Stunden das bekommen,
was sie sonst irgendwie für 4x7 Stunden bekommen wollen.
Ja, das ist mein Reich und wie ich wohne.
Und den Tag starte ich auch netto.
Ich spare viel.
Viele Rücklagen, auch eine schöne Altersvorsorge.
Ich kaufe viele Aktien.
Zwischendurch auch ein bisschen Krypto, Bitcoin, Ethereum.
Dann bis Dienstag.
Danke.
Ruhegeschicht.
Ciao.
Ja, das ist mein Reich.
Und wie ich wohne.
Und den Tag starten wir erstmal mit einem leckeren Frühstück.
Guten Appetit.
Ja, ein Luxus, den ich mir auf jeden Fall gönne, das ist meine Wohnung.
Die ist mir aber auch wichtig.
Das ist mein Rückzugsort.
Da fühle ich mich wohl.
Und man könnte definitiv günstiger wohnen.
Ich bin aber schön vor Ort von Köln gezogen.
In eine verkehrsberuhigte Straße.
Nicht im Assi-Viertel, ja.
Das würde ich auch eindeutig vorziehen.
Und da gefällt es mir sehr gut.
Da fühle ich mich sehr wohl.
Stimmt, wo ist die 30.000 Euro Kaffeemaschine,
die ja die Typen alle haben, die diese Beiträge drehen.
Der Kohleausstieg, der kommt.
Muss es denn ausgerechnet BWL sein?
Gibt es auf dieser Welt nichts anderes, was man studieren kann, außer BWL?
Ist die Zukunft auch für mich noch ungewiss.
Und ich möchte halt in der Zukunft auch weiter bei RWE meinen Platz finden.
Aber wohl in dem Bereich der erneuerbaren Energien.
Und mehr in den wirtschaftlichen Sektor praktisch reinrutschen.
Das jetzige Studium kostet auch insgesamt 11.000 Euro.
Und das bezahle ich mit einer monatlichen Rate von 317 Euro.
Aber ohne Scheiß, das ist sehr feifert, sehr schlau von ihm,
dass ihm das auch klar ist, dass er das nicht bis zur Rente machen kann.
Also erstens wahrscheinlich körperlich nicht.
Und zweitens wird es das bis dahin gar nicht geben.
Also das ist wirklich sehr schlau, dass er auch noch nebenbei studiert.
Ich meine, gut.
Er hat den Vorteil, er hat wahrscheinlich 14 Tage arbeiten, dann 14 Tage frei oder irgendwie sowas.
Also das bietet sich tatsächlich an, wenn man da irgendwie noch Bock drauf hat.
Also das ist wirklich sehr schlau, dass er das macht.
Ich habe wirklich das Glück, einen Job gefunden zu haben, der mir wirklich Spaß macht.
Wo ich mich wirklich wohlfühle.
Ich arbeite in einem super Team zusammen.
Wir sind Kumpels.
Alles Hand in Hand.
Daher kommt ja, glaube ich, sogar das Wort Kumpel.
Für das Geld lohnt es sich definitiv auch.
Irgendwie aus dem Bergbau.
Trostmusik.
Jetzt erst mal ein bisschen ETF stellt.
War nicht interessant.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen.
Hier habt ihr noch viele weitere sehenswerte Videos von Lohnt sich das?
Und das Wichtigste ist.
Das Wichtigste kam jetzt.
Subscribe.
Subscribe and like.
Oder smash den Abo Button.
Was, wenn ich mir so ansehe, was ich am 1. des Monats noch habe.
Kann ich sagen.
Mit 10 Euro kannst du nicht wirklich viel anlegen.
Das stimmt.
Das ist ja auch eines der Probleme, was es in vielen Bereichen gibt.
Dass die Leute gar nichts an Geld beziehungsweise an irgendwie Vermögen großartig aufbauen können über die Jahre.
Weil wenn du nie was über hast, kannst du auch nichts anlegen.
Und ich sehe es bei uns auf der Arbeit.
Es gibt ein paar.
Die verdienen sicherlich auch nicht schlecht.
Die haben am Ende des Monats immer plus minus 0 auf dem Konto.
Bei denen liegt es aber teilweise auch daran.
Also okay.
Manche haben Frauen und Kinder und müssen sie für mehrere schaffen.
Okay.
Die haben ja auch irgendwo was von.
Wenn einem das was gibt.
Okay.
Aber es gibt auch genug Leute, die machen damit alles mögliche.
Und geben es aus und haben dann halt am Ende des Monats nichts.
Plus plus minus 0 auf dem Konto.
Und dann, wenn irgendwas Großes ist.
Ist immer das Beschweren groß.
So nach dem Motto.
Oh ich brauche jetzt keine Ahnung.
Neue Waschmaschine.
Aber jetzt geht das nicht.
Weil Geld.
Und ja gut.
Dann hättest du halt vielleicht mal nicht dein Auto getunt letzten Monat.
Hättest du jetzt auch eine Waschmaschine kaufen können.
Lohnt es sich Softwareentwickler zu sein?
Wenn wir gerade dabei sind und so was.
Gucken wir das jetzt auch gleich hinten drauf.
Lohnt es sich Softwareentwickler zu sein?
Es kommt wahrscheinlich ganz entscheidend darauf an.
Wo und was und wie.
Und was man da so macht.
Und ob es sich lohnt.
Na gut.
Das hängt ganz entscheidend davon ab.
Was man am Ende des Monats überwiesen bekommt.
Und wieviel man dafür arbeiten muss.
Ja.
Es hat ja auch keinen Sinn.
Wenn man 5K überwiesen bekommt.
Allerdings 80 Stunden arbeiten muss.
Ich glaube das weiß ich gar nicht.
Was ist denn eigentlich die zulässige maximale.
Maximale Wochenzeit.
Gibt es da irgendwas gesetzlich geregeltes.
Was das maximale ist.
Was man arbeiten darf.
Also ich weiß.
Es gibt wohl die Regelung.
Dass man.
Zwischen Arbeitsende und Arbeitsbeginn.
Glaube ich mindestens 10 Stunden.
Oder sowas.
Haben muss.
Und dass man glaube ich.
Maximal 11 Stunden am Stück.
Irgendwie arbeiten darf.
Also wahrscheinlich.
Ergibt sich.
Ergibt sich irgendwie daraus.
Ja das ist kompliziert.
Glaube ich auch.
Solche rechtlichen Sachen sind.
Zu sickset für mich.
Der China Spy Balloon wurde runtergeknallt.
Das habe ich auch schon gelesen.
Ja.
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Warum sie da so eine Zeremonie drüber gemacht haben.
Drum gemacht haben.
Na das halte ich.
Das halte ich jetzt aber auch mal für fragwürdig.
Du hast Leute.
Die haben am Ende des Monats.
Wirklich plus minus 0.
Ja.
Was sollen die großartig zurücklegen.
Natürlich.
Wenn die Leute jetzt sagen.
Wir müssen erst mal unser Auto tunen.
Oder sonstigen Blödsinn machen.
Und deswegen kein Geld mehr haben.
Ist das was anderes.
Aber du wirst genug Leute finden.
Die haben.
Vom puren.
Existieren.
Und überleben nicht genug Geld am Ende des Monats übrig.
Und was.
Wahrweise.
Was sollen die großartig sparen.
Wie sollen.
Wo sollen das.
Wo soll das Geld herkommen.
Na können die noch so viele Whatsapp Gruppen reingehen.
Und sich das richtige Mindset antrainieren.
ist, kommt halt auch nichts.
Google mal Bagger 288.
Ordentlicher
Bagger. Poggers
Bagger.
Um nicht zu sagen, Massive
Bagger. Guck mal,
der sieht fast ein bisschen so aus, der Bagger.
Koggers Bagger.
Naja, es kommt ja schon drauf an, was du für
Ausgaben hast. Allein das Gehalt
sagt ja nichts. Wobei 3k
brutto, sag mal, wenn du
vielleicht noch Miete bezahlen musst,
es wird halt knapp, aber
sicherlich, wenn es die gibt, die noch weniger
verdienen. Ich habe gerade
Koggers Bagger verstanden, das ist auch richtig.
Koggers Bagger.
Sieht ja auch so aus wie ein Koggers Bagger.
Das Emote nennt sich Koggers.
Max, es sind 10 Stunden, die man arbeiten
darf, die maximale Arbeitszeit auf nur
8 Stunden, 11 Stunden
waren es zwischen Arbeitsende und
Beginn.
Okay, so, dann gucken wir uns mal an,
ob sich Softwareentwickler lohnt. Das ist jetzt
ein anderer Channel, das wird wahrscheinlich auch ein ganz anderes Video
sein, aber gucken wir, was er
dazu erzählt. Also, unterm Strich hängt es natürlich davon ab, was du
verdienst. Hey Leute, was geht ab und willkommen zu einem
neuen Video. Heute werde ich dir zeigen, wie
der Alltag eines Softwareentwicklers so
ist. Okay, nicht Tischkicker
spielen den ganzen Tag.
Was hat er denn da? Erkennt man
irgendwie, was es für ein Betriebssystem ist? Das ist
eine Idee im Fullscreen, ich erkenne da gar nichts.
Chat, was ist es?
Wer ist Fyfet?
Ich erkenne auch keine macOS-Sachen
oder so, die irgendwie
am Fenster wären.
Also, der Schreibtisch sieht sehr macOS,
stylisch aus, ja, also, aber
mal gucken.
Was die Aufgabenbereiche sind und ob sich
der Job überhaupt lohnt. Und keine Sorge,
wenn du überhaupt keine Ahnung hast, was
Softwareentwicklung überhaupt ist. Warum da
ein Rubik's Cube auf dem Tisch steht, weil es cool aussieht
wahrscheinlich. Das ganze Video so aufbauen, dass
wirklich jeder... Oder er speedcubed schnell,
während er programmiert.
Wir werden also dieses ganze
Fachchinesisch und Techblabla
ein bisschen zur Seite schieben. Und falls du mich
noch nicht kennst, mein Name ist Kevin, ich bin
Softwareentwickler und lebe in München.
Okay, es muss ein Mac
sein, wenn er schon
das Mac-Emoji hat.
Ich habe Wirtschaftsinformatik in Österreich studiert und arbeite
seit knapp 10 Jahren in der IT.
Die ersten 2 Jahre habe ich als Software-Tester
gearbeitet, aber die letzten 7, 8
Jahre arbeite ich professionell
als iOS-Entwickler, programmiere
als... Na gut, dann muss es ja ein Mac
sein, auf dem er entwickelt.
Geht zwar anders, aber praktikabel
nicht wirklich. Für das iPhone. Dort war ich
zuerst bei Freeletics und habe an der Fitness-App
gearbeitet. Danach habe ich einen
Wechsel zu Payback gemacht. Ihr kennt
schon, die euch an der Rewe-Kasse immer
fragen, sammeln Sie Punkte. Dort habe ich
auch an der iOS-App mitgearbeitet.
Mittlerweile bin ich allerdings bei
VipoTV gelandet. Ihr kennt es
wahrscheinlich, das ist dieser TV-Streaming-Anbieter.
Vipo? Ja, von dem habe ich schon mal was gehört.
Was ein Softwareentwickler überhaupt
macht. Denn klar, die Frage ist... Nicht den
ganzen Tag programmieren, wie viele
Leute denken. Das ist absolut berechtigt,
denn die VipoTV-App, die ist
ja eigentlich schon fertig, die kann man ja
schon installieren und was soll man da noch
überhaupt machen?
Aber das ist ein Trugschluss, denn
Software ist in der Entwicklung nie
fertig. Oder hast du dir schon mal überlegt,
wo die ganzen Updates herkommen?
Also, jetzt weiß ich es auch. Das ist der
Grund, warum bei jeder Windows-Version die
Taskleiste neu entwickelt wird.
Die ist einfach zu fertig.
Die geht einfach und sobald sie geht,
sagt Microsoft, okay, wir machen jetzt eine neue.
Da kann man erstmal in
drei verschiedene Aufgabenbereiche
unterteilen. Nummer 1 sind die
Entwicklung neuer Funktionen. Als Beispiel
für eine Funktion, die erst nachträglich
in eine App kam, können wir mal Instagram
nehmen, denn dort gab es zu Beginn
erstmal nur Fotos, die man
posten konnte und später kamen
dann noch die Storys dazu. Und das ist auch
völlig gängige Praxis, dass man nachträglich
Funktionen nachliefert. Punkt Nummer 2
ist die...
Logisch, das liegt ja
auf der Hand, zumal man ja auch ein bisschen
gucken muss, was machen denn
die anderen Anbieter so?
Und Twitter hat es ja öfters
mal probiert, wo ich es nie gecheckt habe, was
bei Twitter da eigentlich los ist.
Twitter hatte ja mal eine Zeit lang
irgendwelche... Gucken, ich muss mal
kurz die Twitter-App aufmachen, ob dieser Shit überhaupt
noch drin ist. Den hat doch keine Sau verwendet.
Doch, tatsächlich, immer noch in der Mitte.
Twitter Spaces.
Benutzt irgendjemand Spaces
und diese komische...
diesen komischen Audio
Chat von Twitter?
Niemand benutzt
das, oder?
So Dinge haben die jetzt schon ein paar Mal probiert, wo ich mich immer
gefragt habe, was zum...
Was ist das?
Was ist das? Ja, das ist der mittlere
Knopf in der Twitter-App,
wo man sich so fragt, was macht der eigentlich?
Ja, man muss ja schon ein bisschen gucken,
was passiert drumherum?
Und man sieht es total oft,
dass wenn bei einem Anbieter was erfolgreich ist,
andere Anbieter versuchen nachzuziehen.
Allein schon aus dem Grund, weil das ja so
ein ständig wechselndes Umfeld ist,
ist das nie fertig.
Zumal es auch immer sinnvolle Sachen
gibt, die man einbauen kann.
Und sei es nur, weil User gesagt
haben, ähm, dieses
und dieses, äh, was weiß ich,
ist nicht gleich offensichtlich
und sowas.
Fertig ist es nie, das stimmt.
Wie bei einem Auto, dass man auch ab und zu mal
in die Werkstatt bringen muss, um beispielsweise
einen Ölwechsel zu machen.
Und die dritte Aufgabe sind Bugfixes.
Und keine Sorge, das hat erstmal nichts mit
Insektenbekämpfung zu tun,
sondern bedeutet eigentlich nur, dass man
Dinge repariert, die irgendwann mal kaputt
gegangen sind.
Oder man sagt, das
Fehlverhalten ist eigentlich gewollt.
Das kommt ja auch, äh, nicht
selten vor.
Wie, das ist kein Bug. Das muss so sein.
Das ist Absicht.
Fehler kann beispielsweise sein, dass du keine Benachrichtigung
mehr bekommst, wenn dich jemand auf WhatsApp
anschreibt. Dort setzt sich dann ein
Entwickler an den Programmcode, so wie
er hier zu sehen ist, und
schaut nach, woran das Problem genau
liegen kann. Es wird eine Code-Änderung...
Erstmal, erstmal, erstmal, also in der Theorie,
in der Theorie ist es so, ja, äh,
erstmal gibt's dann ein Ticket,
für, genau, erstmal gibt's dann,
erstmal gibt's ein Ticket für. Dieses
Ticket muss wahrscheinlich noch irgendeinem, äh,
Überprojekt zugeordnet
werden, und selbstverständlich muss
das in der Budgetplanung berücksichtigt worden
sein, dass du das auf irgendeinen Zeitsammler
oder sowas buchen kannst,
damit dann wieder das Controlling und die Budgetplanung
weiß, was Sache ist. Dazu
musst du das Ganze wahrscheinlich dann im Daily Scrum
auch erzählen, dass du das machst, und wenn
du's gemacht hast,
was auch immer. Wahrscheinlich ist es
nicht so einfach mit, ich mach mal,
das Ding auf und tippe was ein
und dann geht's.
...gemacht und im Idealfall gibt es dann
eine neue Version im App Store, die du
runterladen kannst, die das Problem behebt.
Und an genau so einem Bugfix arbeite
ich heute. Aktuell arbeite ich noch
sehr viel im Homeoffice, deswegen
sieht man hier meinen privaten
Schreibtisch und mein Arbeitszimmer.
Falls du aber mal ein Video aus dem Büroalltag
sehen willst, dann lass es mich auf jeden Fall
unten in den Kommentaren wissen.
Um 10.30 Uhr... Was heißt noch?
Hat er wieder vor, regelmäßig,
ins Büro zu gehen?
...dann unser Daily Meeting. In dieser täglichen
Besprechung gibt dann jeder kurz
Informationen darüber, woran
er gestern gearbeitet hat, woran
er heute arbeiten wird und
welche Probleme er aktuell hat. Das ist
dann eine sehr gute Möglichkeit, um
im Anschluss Hilfe von einem anderen
Entwickler zu bekommen, um gemeinsam
an der Problemlösung zu arbeiten.
Diese Daily Meetings sind in der Softwareentwicklung
absolut gängige Praxis.
Vielleicht habt ihr auch schon mal den Begriff Stand-Up
gehört. Zu Deutsch...
Manche, die cool sein wollen, sagen Daily Scrum.
Obwohl sie überhaupt nicht nach Scrum
arbeiten, nichts der sonstigen machen, was
total bescheuert ist, aber es hört sich cooler an.
Eine Sache, die ich persönlich
doof finde an Daily Meetings,
nicht die Daily Meetings
an sich, sondern,
dass je nachdem, kommt ein bisschen
auf das Unternehmen an, wo man arbeitet,
diese Dailies, gerade wenn dort
der Chef drin ist oder noch irgendwelche anderen
Leute oder irgendwelche Projektleute,
letztendlich auch mit
darüber entscheiden,
welche Aufstiegschancen man hat
für das nächste Gehalt, was auch immer.
Also wenn da Leute dabei sind, die irgendwie
organisatorisch beteiligt sind,
dann arten diese Daily Meetings
oftmals darin aus,
dass die Leute sich selbst
beweihräuchern müssen.
Also sprich, normalerweise
ist das Meeting dafür gedacht,
es ist, also
zumindest von der
reinen Lehre, ist es gedacht,
dass es auch okay ist,
wenn man nichts sagt
in solchen Stand-Ups. So nach dem Motto,
ja, eigentlich
gestern jetzt nichts irgendwie
großartig zu berichten, was
jetzt alle interessieren würde, heute gucke ich
mir das und das an, ja, fertig.
Das müsste eigentlich okay sein,
wenn man das macht,
ist es allerdings oftmals nicht, deswegen
gerade, es gibt ja sogar
Dailies, wo Protokoll geschrieben wird.
Habe ich damals erlebt beim Provider
noch, da gab es Dailies, da wurde
Protokoll geschrieben und da könnt ihr davon ausgehen,
dass die Leute
dazu ja quasi schon gezwungen sind, sich
selbst zu beweihräuchern.
Wo es dann im Endeffekt drauf rausläuft, dass das
Daily für eine Viertelstunde angesetzt ist,
am Ende geht es 45 Minuten
und es werden teilweise die
uninteressantesten Monologe gehalten und
jeder Kleinscheiß
wird aufgeblasen zu
ich habe jetzt quasi mal nebenbei kurz
eine neue Programmiersprache erfunden, so in der
Richtung. Also
das muss sinnvoll gemacht sein,
dann ist es sinnvoll, also
muss gut gemacht sein, muss auch okay
sein, dass man mal sagt, okay, gibt nichts Spannendes.
Wenn das solche Profilierungs-
Dailies sind, dann finde ich die sinnlos.
Das kommt aus der Bürozeit,
wo noch alle Leute im Büro waren
und man sich dann einfach hingestellt
hat im Kreis und dann
die Besprechung gemacht hat. Jetzt nach unserer
Besprechung mache ich mich direkt an die
Und dieses im Kreis hinstellen hatte ja mal den
Ursprungs-Hintergedanken, dass die Leute
dann eben nicht so viel labern, weil
sie halt stehen, aber das hat auch nichts gebracht.
Suche des Bugs. Dazu versuche ich
erstmal diesen Fehler zu reproduzieren.
Das bedeutet, dass ich selbst erstmal
schauen muss, ob ich diesen Fehler
nachstellen kann. Denn erst dann kann ich
vergleichen, ob nach meiner Reparatur
der Fehler behoben wurde.
Dazu benutze ich verschiedene Hilfsmittel.
Zum einen schaue ich mir erstmal den Quellcode
an und selbstverständlich
benutze ich auch die Google-Suche.
Gerade wenn man viel im Homeoffice arbeitet,
ist ein ordentlicher Arbeitsplatz
unerlässlich. Denn dort verbringe ich
eigentlich ein Drittel meines Tages. Das stimmt.
Seit ein paar Monaten nutze ich
einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch.
Okay, ich will mit der Tastatur nicht klarkommen,
aber es hat jeder so seins. Da gebe ich ihm vollkommen
Recht. Und das sehe ich auch oft bei Leuten,
die im Homeoffice nicht klarkommen.
Die sitzen dann in der Küche,
die Kinder springen drum herum,
haben einen Stuhl ohne Armlehnen
und einen Mini-Laptop auf dem Küchentisch
und sowas. Und dann sagen sie
Ich kann im Homeoffice nicht arbeiten.
Das funktioniert nicht. Homeoffice ist scheiße.
Büro ist viel besser.
Gut, dann sorg halt dafür, dass du daheim
gescheit arbeiten kannst. Oder geh halt ins Büro.
Aber tu nicht so, als müsste das jeder machen.
Kommt jetzt ein Placement.
Ich gehe davon aus, weil Flexispot
in der Beschreibung drin
steht.
Flexispot habe ich auch schon sehr laut gemacht.
... von Flexispot.
Und ich kann euch
nicht sagen, wie froh ich bin,
dass ich mittlerweile so einen Schreibtisch habe.
Denn den ganzen Tag zu sitzen, geht irgendwann
mal auf den Rücken. Der Schreibtisch taucht
aber tatsächlich. Deshalb ist gelegentliches
Aufstehen super wichtig.
Wirklich in Ordnung.
... mit einer ziemlich großen Bambusplatte.
Und den Platz, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen,
den brauche ich auch, weil ich mittlerweile
mit mehreren Monitoren arbeite.
Und auch das Gestell ist leistungsstark genug,
um mein riesiges Setup auf-
und abzufahren. Man hat dieses praktische...
Also ich habe auch einen ziemlich langen Tisch.
Einfach, wie gesagt, ist ähnlich wie bei ihm.
Zwei Monitore,
Audio-Interfaces,
Boxen, dann stehen hier teilweise
noch die Konsolen.
Da muss schon ein bisschen was drauf.
Aber mein Schreibtisch sieht
bei weitem nicht so ordentlich aus
wie seiner. Ich erkenne
da aber System dahinter. MacOS-Benutzer
haben gerne aufgeräumte
stylische Schreibtische.
Das zieht sich da so durch.
... damit man ganz einfach
die Höhe verstellen kann und dazu noch
diese vier programmierbaren Buttons.
Ich wechsle also mehrfach am Tag in diesen
Stehmodus und arbeite... Ja, das könnte
ich auch machen. Das mache ich aber nicht, weil ich zu faul bin.
... eine Stunde und dann setze ich
mich wieder für eine Stunde hin und so komme
ich eigentlich super gut durch den Tag.
Das nette ist, dass Flexispot trotz einer sehr
guten Qualität sehr preiswert
sind und, jetzt kommt das coole,
es gibt ziemlich nette Black Friday
Angebote. Wenn du also sowieso schon lange
mal überlegt hast, dir einen höhenverstellbaren
Schreibtisch anzuschaffen, dann check auf
jeden Fall mal unten den Link in der Videobeschreibung
an, denn ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
dass da ein cooles Angebot für dich dabei ist.
Vielen Dank auch nochmal an Flexispot.
Für die Sponsorung dieses Videos.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen weiter mit dem Video.
Für eine professionelle Arbeit benutze ich
übrigens ausschließlich ein Macbook Pro,
denn ich bin beruflich auf
das Mac OS Betriebssystem angewiesen.
Bin mir natürlich dessen bewusst, dass
für die meisten Leute so ein Macbook
viel zu teuer ist. Keine Sorge,
lasst euch von sowas auf gar keinen Fall
Ich gehe davon aus, dass er das wahrscheinlich sogar
von seinem Arbeitgeber gestellt bekommt, weil
die wollen ja, dass er was arbeiten kann.
... abschrecken, denn man kann auch für einen kleinen
Geldbeutel ordentliche Hardware bekommen,
wie zum Beispiel so ein gebrauchtes
Thinkpad für 200 Euro.
Womit man wirklich professionell
Ich persönlich arbeite
nicht gerne an Notebooks.
Man sieht das in ganz
vielen Videos auch, wo wir letztens
geguckt haben, irgendwie bei Google und Facebook,
die hocken alle den ganzen Tag an ihren Notebooks.
Er hat ja wenigstens ordentliche
Monitore und Tastaturen und sowas dran, aber die sitzen wirklich
an ihren Notebooks, arbeiten mit dem Trackpad
und dem Screener drauf.
Ich krieg das nicht hin. Ich brauche meine
fette Desktopkiste, zwei Monitore dran und gut ist.
Also ich würde mit dem Notebook
nicht klar kommen. Ich habe auf der Arbeit
ein Notebook, aber das benutze ich als stationären
Rechner. Also das hängt
bei mir an der
Dockingstation. An der Dockingstation ist der große
Monitor dran. Ich habe eine extra Maus und Tastatur
mitgebracht und
gut ist.
Es ist ein Surface Book, was ich auf der Arbeit
habe mittlerweile.
Die sind gar nicht schlecht und funktionieren unter Linux auch
ganz gut.
Falls du dich für so etwas interessierst,
ich habe mal ein Video dazu gemacht, das ihr euch gerne
hier mal anschauen könnt. Aber mal wieder
zurück zu unserer Code-Fehlersuche.
Ich habe das Problem jetzt auch nachstellen können
und habe auch schon eine Idee, wie ich
das Problem fixen kann. Es ist nicht
unüblich, dass man mal einen ganzen Tag
für die Fehlersuche verbraucht, um
die Wurzel eines Problems zu finden.
Also arbeite ich an einem Tag an einer
Fehlerbehebung und an einem anderen Tag
baue ich eine neue Funktion
in eine App ein. Es ist unmöglich
an einem Tag alle Facetten
eines Berufs zu zeigen, deswegen
kann ich dir wirklich nur empfehlen, diesen Kanal
zu abonnieren, denn in meinen anderen
Videos über die zukünftigen Videos
gibt es wöchentlich Videos.
Wirst du also auch mal lernen,
wie eine neue Funktion entstehen kann.
Ganz spannend ist natürlich auch
das Thema Bezahlung. Es ist bekannt, dass
Softwareentwickler sehr gut verdienen.
Das hängt aber an sehr vielen Faktoren ab.
Zum einen natürlich die Berufserfahrung
der Firma, in der man arbeitet.
Die Branche und vor allem der Standort
ist auch wichtig. Auch die eingesetzte
Technologie. Ich bin mir aber trotzdem sicher,
dass ihr eine genaue Zahl haben wollt.
Deshalb kann ich euch jetzt mal sagen,
was ich als Einstiegsgehalt bekommen habe.
Und zwar lag mein Jahresgehalt
als iOS-Entwickler bei Freeletics
bei 52.000 Euro
im Jahr. Das ist natürlich...
Also mein Einstiegsgehalt, weil wir jetzt gerade dabei sind,
wenn wir gerade dabei sind, also mein
Einstiegsgehalt damals
2007 rum, nee 2010
rum,
wo ich beim Provider angefangen
habe, also
wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe und dann angefangen habe,
hatte ich
als allererstes Gehalt
33.600 Euro.
Dann bin ich ja ein paar Jahre später
gewechselt.
Dann weiß ich nicht, wie viel es war.
Das könnten sowas in dem
Dreh hier
gewesen sein.
Sowas irgendwie in dem Dreh.
Vielleicht.
Bin mir nicht sicher.
Das ist dann hochgegangen
nach ein paar Jahren auf 70k.
Und dann
auf ein bisschen über 70k. Ja und
für einen neuen Job habe ich jetzt
erst ein eigenes Video zugemacht.
Ja, das ist natürlich brutto,
aber raus hat man netto dann circa
2700 Euro.
Man muss noch dazu sagen... Ja und jetzt?
Und jetzt? Das ist jetzt gerade das Interessante.
Das ist jetzt ja eigentlich das Interessante. Wie hat sich das entwickelt?
ist also schon über 7 Jahre her.
Je nachdem, wie gut man sich anstellt,
kann das Gehalt auch in kurzer Zeit
relativ schnell steigen. Aber ohne euch
jetzt eine genaue Zahl nennen zu können,
kann ich euch versichern, dass mein Gehalt natürlich
in 7-8 Jahren deutlich
gestiegen ist. Um jetzt zum Ende des Arbeitstages
zu kommen... Das hätte mich jetzt
wirklich interessiert.
Was ist so... Ich meine, es hätte ja auch
eine Range getan.
Ich habe ja auch in meinem Video eine Range gesagt.
Das hätte mich jetzt tatsächlich
interessiert. Ich konnte glücklicherweise den Fehler
des Problems finden und
meine Codeänderungen sind jetzt wahrscheinlich
schon verfügbar als Update im Appstore.
Aber was kann ich abschließend zum
Beruf des Softwareentwicklers sagen?
Um es kurz zu machen, ich liebe es.
Man ist komplett flexibel, man kann von den
unterschiedlichsten Orten auf der Welt arbeiten
und die Bezahlung ist ziemlich gut.
Ich hoffe, dir hat dieser Einblick in
meinen Alltag als Softwareentwickler gefallen.
Es muss halt auch was für einen sein.
Man muss ganz ehrlich sagen,
Leute, die das nur wegen dem Geld anfangen,
die... Ich glaube nicht,
dass die glücklich werden. Und ich glaube auch nicht,
dass die wirklich gut da drinnen werden.
Du musst dich schon auch persönlich, privat
da voll dafür interessieren.
Guck mal, wir sitzen
so oft hier... Ich meine, gut, man könnte
sagen, ich verdiene hier auch irgendwie
Geld mit, weil es gibt Subscriber auf YouTube,
es gibt Subscriber auf Twitch,
es gibt Werbeeinnahmen auf YouTube, was auch immer.
Aber wir sitzen so oft hier im Stream
und ich gucke mir neue Sachen an, einfach weil es mich
interessiert. Nicht weil ich damit
Geld verdienen will jetzt oder sowas, sondern
einfach weil es mich interessiert.
Und auch wenn ich nicht streame
oder irgendwas anderes mache, gucke ich mir
sau viel neue Technikgeschichten an,
einfach weil es mich interessiert. Und ich glaube,
wirklich gut sind unterm Strich
auch nur die Leute, die sich privat
dafür interessieren und die sich vorher schon für
interessieren und die sich nicht nur dafür
interessieren, weil es da viel Geld zu holen gibt.
Falls ja, dann lass mir
sehr gerne einen Daumen nach oben da.
Falls du mehr dieser Videos sehen möchtest,
dann auf jeden Fall abonnieren und
die Glocke aktivieren. Ich hoffe,
wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal.
Ja, nice. Kann man ja
nur zustimmen eigentlich.
Wie hoch wäre das Einstiegsgehalt heute?
Also, gehen wir mal
davon aus, ich würde den exakt gleichen
Job heute nochmal machen.
Also damals waren es
33.600. Man muss auch sagen,
man muss auch wirklich sagen, also der Provider,
ich habe ja da mal ein eigenes Video drüber gemacht.
Das war schon ein ziemlicher Kackladen, so im Nachhinein
betrachtet.
Also unter 40k sollte es
heute auf jeden Fall nicht sein.
Ja. Ehrlich gesagt finde ich
das, was er gesagt hat mit den 50k
gar nicht so verkehrt als Einstieg.
Kommt auf
die Region an, kommt auf die
Branche an. Ich meine, ich habe wirklich
Glück. Es gab letztens
eine Umfrage, welche Branchen
die höchsten Gehälter haben.
Da sind Banken auf Platz 1
und Versicherungen, so glaube ich, also
Finanzbranche auf Platz 1.
Ich glaube auf Platz 2 Pharmaindustrie
und
Zeug. Warte mal.
Branchengehalt.
Ich sollte vielleicht IT
auch dazu sagen. Ach, keine Ahnung,
wo ich das gefunden habe.
Warte mal.
Die Pharmaindustrie. Du meinst
China, Chinesen, Goldfarmen bei MMO.
Sag ich mal, die Pharmaindustrie.
Ja.
Also, da habe ich natürlich Glück,
dass ich in der Finanzbranche bin
und in Frankfurt. Das ist natürlich
eine Kombination. Da gibt es ordentlich
Kohle. Frankfurt ist eh schon, was
Gehaltstechnik angeht, ganz nice und
Finanzbranche nochmal doppelt.
Da hat letztens einer
ein interessantes Kommentar
unter einem YouTube Comment
und ein YouTube Video von mir gepostet.
Ich kann es nicht mehr eins zu eins
wiedergeben und YouTube Suche ist kacke.
Ich werde das Comment jetzt wahrscheinlich auch
nicht finden. Ich meine, wir können es
ja mal kurz ausprobieren, ob ich es finde.
Müsste irgendwo
hier in dem Video sein.
Eines der letzten Comments, wo ich drauf
geantwortet habe. Müssen wir mal gucken.
Wo ich drauf geantwortet habe, werden
wir ja relativ schnell finden.
So, weil...
Hier, das da. Genau.
Ich glaube,
da hat er das nochmal editiert.
Ne, hat er nicht.
Der hat hier geschrieben, quasi,
niemals drüber reden, wie viel man verdient.
Mir juckt es schon in den Fingern hier zu schreiben,
wie unfair es ist, dass in der IT
fürstlich ein Lohn wird. Und ich mach mal kurz
ein bisschen Gedudel an.
Dass in der IT fürstlich ein Lohn wird,
während normale Fachkräfte mit
geringverdienten Geldern abgespeist werden.
Was rechtfertigt, das fand ich
den interessanten Part tatsächlich
in dieser Frage.
Was rechtfertigt, dass die IT
so deutlich besser bezahlt wird?
Meinen Job kann auch nicht jeder machen.
Warum kann mein Chef das Wort Gehaltshöhle
nicht mal buchstabieren, während meine Freunde IT
mitunter eine Gehaltshöhle nach der anderen bekommen?
Wir arbeiten alle in großen Unternehmen,
die Tarifverträge haben, nur sind die
ITs manchmal besser. Also,
man darf nicht
bei diesen ganzen Fragen,
das ist auch das, was ich ihm sinngemäß geantwortet habe,
es geht hier gar nicht um fair oder
unfair oder gerechtfertigt, weil
was bedeutet gerechtfertigt? So nach dem Motto,
wer tut mehr für die Menschheit?
So nach dem Motto. Ja, dann müsste man natürlich
Alten- und Krankenpflegen sicherlich mehr
bezahlen als Leute in der IT.
Unterm Strich ist es ganz banal,
um was es geht. Es geht um Geld.
Es wird das gemacht,
was sich lohnt. Und gerade
in der Finanzbranche,
sagen wir mal, gerade IT in der
Finanzbranche, da muss man sich fragen,
was kostet es, also wenn du Millionen
über Trading und andere
Sachen, wenn du Millionen damit machst,
da musst du dich fragen, was
kostet ein Ausfall?
Was kann ich dagegen machen?
Wie viel
muss ich den Leuten bezahlen, dass sie zu mir kommen
und nicht woanders hingehen?
Wie viele Leute brauche ich, die dafür sorgen,
dass meine Systeme funktionieren und nicht kaputt gehen?
Was gebe ich aus,
was gebe ich aus
für Hochverfügbarkeit?
Und das alles in Kombination
ist das, was die Gehälter
letztendlich ausmacht. Es geht nicht
darum, dass die Leute, die
in der IT arbeiten, jetzt irgendwie
was Besseres für die Menschheit
tun würden oder sonst was.
Es wird das gemacht, was sich
auszahlt. Deswegen
verdienst du in der Finanzbranche
IT-technisch
wahrscheinlich auch potenziell
mehr als woanders, weil
gemacht wird, was sich unterm Strich auszahlt.
Das wird nicht aus reiner
Nächstenliebe gemacht, sondern
das ist einfach
kalkuliert und das
lohnt sich unterm Strich.
Deswegen wird das gemacht.
Und da muss man keine Antwort
darauf suchen, so nach dem Motto,
wer macht jetzt mehr für die Menschheit?
Das ist überhaupt nicht die Frage.
Das ist überhaupt nicht so sinngemäß,
habe ich mir auch was drauf geahnt heute.
Genau, am Ende ist das eine riesige
Kosten-Nutzen-Frage. Gerade im Finanzsektor
wird unglaublich viel Geld bewegt.
Dementsprechend ist da auch gewisser Druck dahinter,
dass alles funktioniert. Das heißt, wie viel kostet
ein Ausfall? Wie viel kostet Hochverfügbarkeit?
Was kostet mit anständiges Personal?
Wie viel muss man bezahlen, damit die Leute
nicht woanders hingehen?
Und unterm Strich wird das gemacht, was sich
auszahlt, beziehungsweise was sich lohnt.
Und dazu gehört halt auch, dass man
Experten, die man haben will, gut bezahlen muss.
Die alles am Laufen halten
und weiterentwickeln. Dass irgendwie
da jetzt eine Rechtfertigung drinnen zu suchen,
im sozialen Sinne, wer jetzt mehr
für das Wohl der Menschheit tut,
das muss man da nicht suchen.
Es wird unterm Strich das gemacht,
was sich
rechnet und was sich auszahlt.
Ob man das jetzt gut oder
schlecht finde, das kann jedem selbst überlassen
sein, aber das ist der Grund,
warum die Leute in der IT dann mehr Geld verdienen.
Es ist halt einfach
nicht der richtige Ansatz zu fragen,
wie ist die Rechtfertigung? Die Rechtfertigung
ist Geld.
Das ist alles.
Das ist immer, also so gut wie immer, die Rechtfertigung
bei solchen Sachen. Das ist, weil sich's lohnt.
Weil sich's lohnt.
Und das Lohnen
wird halt an
an Geld irgendwie festgemacht.
Nicht an Menschenleben, nicht an
irgendwie, hab ich jetzt was Tolles
für die Menschheit gemacht? Nee.
Rein an, wie viel Geld kannst du verdienen?
Weil wenn's wirklich nach
so irgendwie, so im sozialen Sinne
drum geht hier, wer macht jetzt mehr für
die Menschheit? Ja, dann dürftest
du wahrscheinlich mir und ihm,
ihm wahrscheinlich auch,
gar nicht so viel Geld bezahlen. Da müsstest du
andere, da müsstest du andere
deutlich, deutlich besser bezahlen. Aber
daran ist das halt gesellschaftlich
auch nicht ausgerichtet. Da kann man
sich jetzt drüber aufregen und sagen,
oh, das ist kacke. Sicherlich, ja,
kann man da sich drüber streiten,
ob das gut ist. Aber es ist nun mal so.
Genau, das ist nämlich,
du hast Recht, das ist die eigentliche Frage, die man stellen könnte.
Also, wo ist denn die Rechtfertigung?
Warum kriegen denn die anderen so wenig?
Das ist, das ist die eigentliche Frage.
Und die Antwort ist genau die gleiche.
Weil sie
nicht so viel Kohle machen im Endeffekt damit.
Jemand, der im Altersheim
arbeitet, der Rentner im Altersheim,
der kostet nur Geld.
So. Und dementsprechend ist es natürlich
auch schwierig, damit über die Runden zu kommen,
den Leuten ordentlich was zu bezahlen. Wobei das
jetzt auch schon, langsam
aber sicher, ein bisschen
umschlägt. Und das will ich auch hoffen.
Das will ich auch wirklich hoffen.
Weil es gibt immer weniger Leute, die das machen wollen.
Die finden auch immer weniger Leute,
die sie anwerben können. Jetzt sagen wir mal irgendwie aus
Polen oder sonst wie. Die will ja auch keiner mehr machen.
Und die Leute
rennen da reihenweise weg.
Das heißt, den
wird über kurz oder lang nichts übrig
bleiben, als sie besser zu bezahlen.
Aktuell ist es ja eher hohle
Versprechung. So nach dem Motto
wir werden jetzt was machen und dann tut sich
zwei Jahre nichts.
Aber unterm Strich geht es einzig und allein darum,
wer ist bereit Geld auszugeben
und das sind die, die quasi damit
auch besonders viel Geld verdienen können.
Und im Finanzsektor und
man könnte auch sagen, im IT-Sektor
IT für sich genommen
jetzt nicht, aber IT ist ja meistens
in bisschen was größeres
eingegliedert und da wird viel Geld
verdient und dementsprechend bezahlen
die die Leute auch entsprechend.
Wenn es
jetzt nach
Arbeitsleistung
oder
nach wie sehr
nimmt einen der Job mit oder sowas geht,
da müsstest du andere sicherlich noch besser bezahlen.
Aber ich werde mich nicht beschweren. Ich werde sicherlich
nicht sagen, gib mir weniger Geld.
Das stimmt. Habe ich auch von vielen gehört.
Also meine Mutter, die
macht das ja schon eine ganze Weile.
Meine Mutter war ja früher Krankenschwester.
Von der kenne ich das noch von früher, da hat die sich schon immer drüber beschwert.
Und mittlerweile
ist es wohl ganz schlimm, dass
im Gesundheits- und Pflegebereich
die Arbeitsbedingungen aus mehreren Gründen
kacke sind. Also nicht
so sehr das Gehalt, aber letztendlich
ist das
Geld, was du verdienen kannst, das Hauptproblem.
Auch weil
die Arbeitsbedingungen automatisch
besser werden dadurch, dass du mehr Leute hast.
Und wenn du mehr Leute, also
es muss irgendjemand mal die Entscheidung treffen,
wir nehmen
jetzt mehr Geld in die Hand. Und mehr Geld
in die Hand nehmen bedeutet, okay
fuck, wir haben realisiert, wir haben zu wenig
Leute, wir nehmen mehr Geld in die Hand. Das heißt, wir bezahlen
den Leuten mehr. Und dadurch, dass wir den Leuten
mehr bezahlen, machen es auch wieder mehr Leute.
Und dadurch, dass du mehr Leute hast,
die da drin arbeiten in dem Bereich,
verbessern sich für die anderen auch wieder die Arbeitsbedingungen.
Ja und Organisation und Arbeitsbedingungen
sind, also Arbeitsbedingungen gerade im Pflege-
und Gesundheitsbereich sind komplett für den Arsch.
Und worüber sich meine Mutter immer aufgeregt hat, ist,
das war die Zeit, wo
eingeführt wurde, dass du wirklich
jeden Furz, den du lässt, in irgend so
ein Formular eintragen musst,
wo die dann irgendwann auch gesagt hat, ich hab keinen Bock
mehr. Und das könnt ihr euch überlegen, meine Mutter
ist jetzt, ich denk grad wie alt
die ist, ich glaub 71 oder so.
Ich weiß es gar nicht, ich glaub
70, nee, 72, ich weiß
nicht, um die 70, bisschen über
70.
Und ihr könnt euch vorstellen, das ist schon eine ganze
Weile her. Und die hat immer gesagt,
also warum sie keinen Bock mehr aufs Krankenhaus
hatte, ist, weil die ganze,
der ganze Dokumentations-
Wahnsinn total überhand genommen
hat. Also du konntest dich, die war in
der Kinderstation,
also
wie heißt denn das? Ja, Kinder,
ich glaub Kinderstation heißt das.
Und die hat gemeint, sie konnten sich nicht mehr wirklich
drum kümmern.
Den, also ein Beispiel,
ein Beispiel, was sie immer gebracht hat, ist,
da hast du, da hast du
ja öfters mal Kinder, die haben Verdauungsprobleme
oder sonst was. Ja, die ist,
auf der Kinderstation, die sind ja nicht alle sterbenskrank.
Ne, die, die haben,
die haben halt irgendwas so. Und es gibt Erkrankungen,
da musst du extra Essen für die
machen. Ja, sei es irgendein extra Spezial-
Brei, oder auch
mal kurz mit der Kantine telefonieren, dass es
was Spezielles gibt. So, und die hat erzählt, früher
konnten sie beispielsweise, wenn die wussten, hey,
keine Ahnung, Patient 75 hier,
der und der auf dem Zimmer,
die, der hat Verdauungsprobleme,
da haben die, konnten die für den extra Essen
machen, extra Brei anrühren.
Und da hat sie gesagt, irgendwann ging das nicht mehr.
Weil die erstens gar nicht
abweichen durften vom normalen Plan
und, weil das pure
erstellen so, so dieses
ich mach jetzt Brei für den, quasi
drei Formulare hätte ausfüllen müssen dafür.
Und du mehr damit beschäftigt
warst, die Formulare auszufüllen dafür, dass
du jetzt Brei machen darfst, als dass du ihm Brei gemacht
hast. Und dann hat sie
irgendwann gesagt, hab ich keinen Bock mehr drauf, und ist aus dem Krankenhaus
weg. Was ich auch
nachvollziehen kann. Ja, also deswegen
fand ich dieses Comment von ihm ganz interessant, also
unterm Strich kann man einfach sagen, es wird
das gemacht, was sich lohnt.
So ist das bei uns im
Business Sektor nun mal.
Kann sich drüber streiten,
ob das gut ist, aber
nach irgendwie einer
großen Rechtfertigung suchen muss man da
nicht. Und außerdem
muss man die umgedrehte Frage stellen,
was rechtfertigt es denn, dass die anderen so
Scheiße bezahlt werden. So, gucken wir mal,
was gibt es denn sonst noch Neues.
Was können wir sonst noch gucken. Also
Handwerkstechnisch ist glaube ich aktuell gar
nicht mal so übel.
Du hast mega Probleme Handwerker zu bekommen.
Wenn einer was macht, ist es auch nicht
billig. Ich möchte mir
beispielsweise ein neues
Hoftor machen lassen.
Finde mal einen, der Hoftore macht. Finde mal einen, der
das irgendwie im nächsten Jahrtausend erledigt.
In diesem Jahrtausend auch erledigt.
Und irgendwas, wo du sagst,
okay, das was ich bekomme und das was
es kostet, spricht mich irgendwie an.
Also ich habe bis jetzt noch
nichts gefunden.
Das beste Beispiel dafür war doch,
wo ich nach einem Elektriker gesucht habe.
Der mir ein
Ladegerät fürs Elektroauto
fürs Elektroauto
an die Wand machen sollte.
Ich habe sieben, acht Handwerker bei mir
angerufen. Die haben alle
gesagt, ja irgendwie in einem halben
Jahr oder so könnte ich mal wieder fragen.
Und dann
habe ich einen anderen angerufen. Da war
irgendjemand mit polnischem
Akzent oder sowas dran.
Und dem habe ich das erzählt. Und das erste,
was der gemeint hat,
das wird teuer.
Und da dachte ich mir auch schon, okay,
ich habe dir noch gar nicht genau erzählt,
was ich eigentlich wie haben will.
Also sprich, ohne Scheiß, ich habe gesagt,
ich suche jemanden, der mir ein Ladegerät
an die Wand bauen kann. Und bevor der
gefragt hat, um was geht es denn genau,
wie soll das angeschlossen werden, war das
erste, das wird kosten, hat er gesagt.
Nicht das wird teuer, das wird kosten,
hat er gesagt. Das wird kosten.
Und da habe ich auch schon gedacht, okay,
das klang jetzt nicht sonderlich seriös.
Zu dem bin ich da nicht hingegangen.
Und der Einzige, der es instant
gemacht hätte, wäre wahrscheinlich dieser,
das wird kosten Typ gewesen.
Ich habe dann aber doch noch
Glück gehabt, irgendwie den siebten oder achten
Handwerker, den ich angerufen habe,
den habe ich auf
dem falschen Fuß erwischt. Und er hat
mir zugesagt, das zu machen, bevor er irgendwie in seinen
Kalender geguckt hat, hat sich dann auch tatsächlich
daran gehalten.
Also, das ist tatsächlich nicht einfach.
Und dementsprechend lassen die sich das auch
bezahlen.
Vollkommen zu Recht.
Wenn du dich nicht mehr retten kannst vor Aufträgen,
ist das einfachste, was du machen kannst. Ey, wisst ihr
was? Dann mache ich es einfach teurer
und nehme die, die bereit sind, das zu bezahlen.
Ist doch ganz einfach. Keine Ahnung.
Da ist schon ein bisschen was
dran. Also, wenn man
das jetzt mal vergleicht, nehmen wir mal
das, was ich mache, mit dem, vergleichen
wir das mal mit dem Berg, mit dem
Bergarbeiter, wo wir vorhin das Video geguckt haben.
Also, der
Kerl hat mit Sicherheit den
deutlich anstrengenderen Job,
also körperlich
auf jeden Fall und
belastungstechnisch mit Sicherheit auch.
Schichtarbeit,
Nacht, Nachteinsätze
und was nicht
alles,
regelmäßig, 14 Tage am Stück
arbeiten und solche Geschichten.
Der hat mit Sicherheit
den deutlich anstrengenderen
Job als ich und
wir verdienen ungefähr das gleiche.
Also, da muss man nicht
irgendwie den Sinn fragen.
Ja, genau, das muss ich
alles jetzt erstmal ein bisschen aufschaukeln,
dass das funktioniert. Und leider
wird es wahrscheinlich so sein, dass
bevor was passiert, mal wieder
irgendwelche Leute im Altersheim
sterben müssen, weil gerade zufällig
kein Pfleger da war.
Und dann gibt es einen riesen Aufschrei, wie kann
das denn sein?
Und wahrscheinlich wird dann
manchmal was gemacht, so nach dem Motto
am grundsätzlichen Problem
geändert, sondern es wird gesagt,
ah, dann müssen die Pfleger es noch
engmaschiger dokumentieren, was sie
machen, anstatt einfach mal 3 neue Leute
hinzusetzen.
Wahrscheinlich reicht das auch nicht.
Würden im Altersheim
würden im Altersheim
quasi mit jedem
Tag Ausfall
15 Millionen Euro
da irgendwie
irgendeinem durch die Lappen gehen, was
meint ihr, wie schnell dort mehr
Pfleger und wie schnell dort mehr qualifizierte
Leute und bessere Arbeitsbedingungen werden?
Sobald es kostet,
sobald es um viel
Kohle geht,
geht das sag ich,
aber das ist da halt nicht so.
Im IT-Sektor,
ich kann es euch erzählen bei uns,
ich sage jetzt keine genauen Zahlen,
aber bei uns wird es so gerechnet,
dass in 15 Minuten Ausfall,
ich sage jetzt mal random,
15 Minuten
Ausfall kostet 1 Millionen Euro.
Da kannst du davon ausgehen,
da ist ein gewisses
Interesse dahinter,
zu gucken, dass das nicht passiert.
Weil ganz klar ist
eine Reaktion, also es wird ganz klar
was kosten, wenn was passiert.
Und dementsprechend haben die da auch
weniger Schmerzen mit zu sagen, weißt du was,
das kostet so viel, wenn der
Scheiß kaputt geht,
lasst uns mal lieber 2 Leute mehr hinsetzen,
die im Zweifelsfall zum größten Teil Däumchen
drehen, aber wenn es dann
der Fall ist, ist die ganze Sache
schneller behoben.
Man könnte zum Beispiel sagen, ok, warum setzen
wir nicht jemand, warum setzen wir nicht
jemand ins Rechenzentrum, machen wir nicht,
nur mal so als Beispiel, was man sich überlegen könnte,
warum setzen wir nicht jemand ins Rechenzentrum,
der den ganzen Tag
bezahlt wird fürs Däumchen drehen,
aber dafür im Ernstfall ganz schnell
dort was machen kann.
So und dann wird das durchgerechnet, sagen wir ok,
der Typ kostet uns, keine Ahnung,
80.000 Euro im Jahr,
uns kosten allerdings 15 Minuten
Ausfall 1 Millionen Euro,
der Typ sorgt dafür, dass so ein
Ausfall anstatt einer Stunde vielleicht nur noch
20 Minuten dauert, easy, machen wir.
Natürlich kannst du noch einrechnen,
wie hoch ist die Chance, dass was passiert,
dann wird das gemacht, dann hast du irgendeinen Job, sitzt halt
ein Typ rum, macht nicht wirklich was, verdient ganz gut
Kohle, aber sorgt
dafür, dass wenn es dann richtig Geld kostet,
es sich in Grenzen hält.
So wird es dann dann unterm Strich
gerechnet. Und sobald da
Kohle dahinter ist und Kohle drin ist, dann geht
das auch immer ganz schnell.
Wie gesagt, ich sag ja nur,
warum das so ist, ich sag ja nicht,
ob das jetzt gut oder schlecht ist,
letztendlich muss sich das auch jeder selbst überlegen,
ob er, wie es gerade läuft, gut oder schlecht
findet. Ich sag euch ja nur, warum das
aus meiner Sicht so ist.
Und das es keinen Grund
oder keinen Sinn macht, dort
irgendwie nach irgendeiner Rechtfertigung
zu suchen, warum jetzt jemand
in der IT mehr verdient als jemand
im Altersheim. Da gibt es keine
Rechtfertigung im sozialen Sinne für
wer tut mehr für die Menschheit. Da geht es
einzig und allein um Geld unterm Strich.
Fertig. Die bezahlen den Leuten
doch in der IT auch keine 80
K plus im Jahr, weil sie so
ihre
Nächstenliebe entdeckt haben. Die bezahlen
den Leuten 80 K plus im Jahr,
weil es für sie unterm Strich
Geld bringt. Ganz einfach.
Oder beziehungsweise in irgendeiner
Art und Weise Geld bringt. Vielleicht auch
Geld spart
in anderen Regionen. Unterm Strich bringt es
mehr als das es kostet.
Deutlich mehr.
Deswegen kann man das machen. Deswegen wird das da
auch gemacht. Wie ist eigentlich das
Verhältnis zu deinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber?
Relativ normal. Außer, dass ich nicht
wirklich motiviert bin was zu machen jetzt.
Jetzt nicht mehr die letzten 1,5 Monate.
Das kann durchaus sein.
Korrekt. Das sind
zum Beispiel so Sachen, die da rauskommen.
Wenn bei der alten Pflegerin
die Waschmaschine kaputt ist daheim,
kann sie sich keine neue kaufen, weil sie nicht genug Geld hat.
Ja, aber das ist eigentlich genau
das Richtige. Das ist genau das Richtige, was
passieren muss. Die Leute dürfen
die Jobs nicht mehr machen und
der Druck muss so groß
werden, dass man ihnen letztendlich
die Jobs wieder schmackhaft machen
möchte.
Das ist doch in vielen
Sektoren so.
Man quetscht die Leute bis
zum Äußersten aus.
So nach dem Motto, ja eigentlich
müssten bei dieser Schicht jetzt
zwei Leute da sein, aber
es ist nur noch einer da und wenn
man dann sieht, dass der eine das
auch schafft, obwohl diese Schicht für zwei
Leute besetzt ist und
dass der dann zwar vielleicht nach drei Jahren
komplett im Arsch ist und erstmal
in psychische Behandlung gehen muss,
interessiert keinen. Der wird dann
drei Jahre ausgepresst. Also das
Beste, was die Leute tatsächlich machen können
ist, zu sagen, ich scheiß drauf
und mach was anderes.
Was natürlich
unterm Strich wieder für die Patienten doof ist,
beziehungsweise
für die Leute, also
Leute, die in diesem Bereich arbeiten, gerade
die Leute, die in der Pflege arbeiten oder im Altersheim,
die haben natürlich schon eine gewisse
soziale
Bezug zum Sozialen und denen fällt das
sicherlich schwer zu sagen,
ich lass die Leute da jetzt im Stich.
Das Problem ist aber, die machen sich
eher selber kaputt, als die Leute im Stich
zu lassen. Und dann
sieht keiner, dass es
nicht funktioniert. Also das Beste, was die
machen können, ist zu sagen, ich mach den Scheiß
nicht mehr unter euren Bedingungen, macht
euren Kack alleine.
Das ist tatsächlich, so blöd sie ist, das ist das
Beste, was sie machen können. Weil
irgendwann wird der Druck so hoch, dass
Geld in die Hand genommen werden muss, dass es
wieder funktioniert.
Anders wird es nicht funktionieren.
Ja, also wie gesagt, da hat sich ja meine Mutter schon drüber beschwert.
Und das war vor
30 Jahren oder so, könnt ihr euch vorstellen, das war,
ist heute noch schlimmer. Dann soll sich
die Öffentlichkeit aufregen über die
Pfleger. Da hat die, die Öffentlichkeit
regt sich über jeden Scheiß auf. Guckt doch mal auf Twitter.
Da musst du einen falschen Furz lassen und die
Öffentlichkeit regt sich auf. Scheiß drauf, die Öffentlichkeit
sich aufregt. Außerdem kann dir
das ja dann egal sein, du hast ja gekündigt.
Sollen sie sich halt aufregen.
Und wenn sie sich aufregen, sollen sie den
Scheiß selber machen. Das wird
nur funktionieren, wenn der Druck groß genug ist,
dass Geld in die Hand genommen wird und die Arbeitsbedingungen
verbessert werden. So, um das wieder attraktiver zu machen,
dass es jemand machen will.
Ansonsten wird das auf lange Sicht nicht klappen.
Und ich glaube, dass wir das jetzt auch im Ansatz
schon sehen. Aktuell.
Ja, naja gut. Also was
können wir uns, haben wir noch irgendwas? Komm, wir haben bestimmt noch
genug Witz. Weil von, von solchen
nervigen,
unangenehmen Themen wegzukommen.
Sieben Programmierer, sieben
Filme. Moment, das habe ich schon mal geguckt, das kenn ich schon.
Aber das haben wir auf einem anderen Channel geguckt.
Päh. Das ist,
das ist geil, das brauche ich.
Ein, ein
Kirby-Absauger.
Wenn ich, wenn ich löte,
ja das ist, das ist, das ist nice.
Das, das ist nice.
Was das ist?
Äh, nö, nö, nö.
Wie heißt das? Dampfab, wie heißt
denn das? Was heißt, was heißt denn, das heißt nicht
Dampf, das heißt, ähm,
Rauch, Rauch, Rauchabzug
ist das. Rauch, genau.
Rauch, Rauchabzug. Also wenn du zum Beispiel
was lötest und da gibt es Dämpfe, Dämpfe
trifft es glaube ich in dem Fall besser.
Dämpfe, ähm, dann
kannst du es absaugen lassen mit dem, guck.
Das wird hier gelötet und das Ding saugt.
Man muss aber dazu sagen,
das ist so eigentlich auch schon relativ
schwachsinnig, ja. Der, der pustet
im ganzen Zimmer rum. Also das kann
man machen, wenn man mal kurz was lötet
und es nur nicht ins Gesicht bekommen will
und direkt, und direkt danach lüftet
oder so. Ein ordentlicher Absauger
hat irgendwie eine Möglichkeit, das, das
abzuführen. Irgendwohin. Ich meine, so
ein Filter ist schon mal
nicht verkehrt, ja. Aber ein ordentlicher Absauger
hat irgendwo was, wo es reingeht.
Und wenn du richtig, wenn du richtig
coole Absauger hast,
ähm, wenn du richtig, wenn du
richtig cooles Absauge,
Absaugeding hast, dann ist das was in der Werkstatt,
was so verbunden ist, dass es rausgeht.
Das ist ein cooles Teil.
Leider könnte ich es nicht gescheit ausdrucken,
bei mir, weil dann müsste ich permanent
Filament wechseln im 3D-Drucker.
Mein 3D-Drucker hat ja nur eine Farbe, also
nur eine Rolle, da müsste ich zwischendurch wechseln.
Wobei, müsste ich nicht, doch, ich müsste wechseln.
Ich müsste für die Füße wechseln, ausdrucken, einzeln
und für den, für den, für das, ähm,
den Ball quasi
wechseln und das andere malt man dann
wahrscheinlich an. Was haben wir, was können wir
uns sonst noch angucken?
Ach ja, ein Monitor. Monitor wollte ich mir anschauen.
Weil es der Monitor, also ich hab schon
seit der Ankündigung,
äh, seit der Ankündigung
einen Blick drauf geworfen, auf den
Monitor.
Und den will ich mir seit Anfang
ankaufen. Um was geht es so in deinen Streams?
In dem heute geht es um nichts Konkretes.
Wenn du wissen willst, was
ich normalerweise so mache, dann kannst
du ins WOT gucken. Guck mal, wir haben sogar
richtig, richtig high IQ,
haben sogar eine extra Archiv-Seite, wo man sich
die WOTs angucken kann.
Sonntagmorgen ist immer sinnloses Zeug-Geschwätze.
Ja, also
auf den Monitor habe ich schon von Anfang an
ein Auge geworfen, weil
das der erste OLED-Monitor
ist mit 240 Hz.
Ich spekuliere
drauf, dass dieses Jahr noch ein bisschen mehr
rauskommt in dieser Richtung,
aber auf den LG-Monitor gucke ich
seit Anfang an. Deswegen bin ich mal gespannt,
wie sich das Ding jetzt so in der Praxis
wirklich schlägt.
Warum ist das hard to believe?
7-inch form factor running at
240...
Ohne Mist, ich habe gar keinen Abzug.
Ich habe
gar keinen Abzug. Ich habe einen
USB-Ventilator.
Und den USB-Ventilator, den stelle ich manchmal
daneben, wenn ich es nicht ins Gesicht kriegen will.
Und wenn ich fertig bin,
dann mache ich einfach
das Fenster auf für eine Viertelstunde.
Ne, ich glaube, Overdrive in dem Form
gibt es da nicht mehr.
Das Panel soll nicht so gut sein wie beim TV.
Was ich gehört habe, ist,
er soll ein bisschen Helligkeitsprobleme haben.
Dass er nicht hell genug ist.
Das reicht.
Ja, ja, wenn du jetzt nicht da sitzt
und den ganzen Tag lötest und deine ganze
Werkstatt
voll dampfst, brauchst du da wahrscheinlich
auch gar nichts. Gucken wir mal.
Was sagt er zu dem Monitor?
Moment, ist das nicht
der Dude, der uns auch letztens was über
AI-Technologie erzählt?
Und in dem ganzen Video vielleicht zwei
sinnvolle Sachen gesagt hat?
Moment, ist das, ist das der?
Ne, anscheinend nicht.
Dann bringe ich das vielleicht,
Wolle, dankeschön für den Sub, dann bringe ich das vielleicht
durcheinander,
dass es dann doch ein anderer war.
Ich finde es nicht.
Das muss doch in der History drinstehen.
Irgendwas mit
Tools hieß das doch.
AI-Teal, ja.
Ach ne, das war der Typ. Ok, ne, die sehen sich noch nicht mal
ansatzweise ähnlich.
Was, der Monitor hat dieses Clear-Type
Grün-Rot-Problem mit den Schriften an den
Rändern, ok.
Ja, das coole ist halt
bei OLED-Bildschirmen, also erstens die Reaktionszeit
und zweitens, dass es
eben der Kontrast auch richtig gut ist.
Weil
aus heißt aus.
Also der Pixel ist dann aus.
Der blockt nicht das Licht,
aber das ist einfach aus.
Genau.
Aber meine Frage, was haltet ihr von
von technischer IT?
Was?
Was soll denn technische IT sein?
Ist IT nicht immer technisch?
Technische Informations...
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Stimmt irgendwas aus der
aus der Schweiz oder Österreich.
Achso.
Ja, genau.
Ok, ich weiß nicht, was technische Informatik sein soll.
Asus.
Monitore abfilmen ist immer so ein
Ding. Ja, man sieht Unterschiede, aber
seriously, es ist schwierig
einzuschätzen, was jetzt wirklich besser aussieht.
Du siehst, hier ist das Bild insgesamt
könnte man annehmen
vielleicht ein bisschen kontrastreicher.
Es könnte aber einfach sein, dass es
insgesamt ein bisschen dunkler ist.
Was ich auch sagen würde, es ist
insgesamt dunkler. Guckt euch mal
guckt euch mal hier so das Material an.
Also, das ist immer sehr schwer
zu sagen, von abgefilmt
bei Monitoren zu sagen.
In comparison. In person I will say
the difference is a lot more dramatic
than what you're probably seeing here on camera.
Ja, genau, wie gesagt, so abgefilmt.
Man sieht einfach, der Monitor ist
rechts würde ich sagen, ist deutlich dunkler insgesamt.
You can hopefully
appreciate how much deeper and richer
the OLED panel looks versus IPS.
And I've got to say, at least in terms of
the image quality, this is easily
the best looking gaming monitor
that I've ever seen. Like, just the overall punchiness
of the image and how clear everything
is. The dark areas, they look
truly dark and they have depth to them.
And the bright areas don't have any of that kind
of like haze that you see on IPS.
Everything just looks a bit more 3D.
Also, keep in mind that the PG27
here, it's a pretty top tier
monitor in terms of IPS panels. It's by
no means a bad looking display,
but it just goes to show how much better the OLED
is in comparison. Now, some of you might have
noticed that the coating here, the kind of surface
finish that goes on top of the panel, is not
a glossy finish that you find on most
OLED Displays. Aber man sieht, dass
also, ich ver... ich denke, dass...
ich denke mal, das ist er hier, oder?
Die Blickwinkelabhängigkeit ist bei OLED
auch ganz gut.
Du kannst in Nvidia GeForce Experience
nicht plus 15 Kontrast machen.
Das funktioniert nicht. Du kannst
Sättigung und so Zeug einstellen,
das ändert aber nichts an dem,
was dein Monitor in...
Wo müssen wir hin?
...in der Lage ist anzuzeigen.
Du kannst das hier hochstellen, aber
dadurch wird das, was dein Monitor
als schwarz anzeigen kann, nicht
schwärzer bei einem LCD.
Weil bei einem LCD
hast du deine Hintergrundbeleuchtung und
das Licht wird halt, sagen wir mal, geblockt an der Stelle.
...Example.
And here instead, it's technically a
matte finish, it's more typical of what you'll find
on a gaming monitor. That sounds like a
really bad thing to slap on top of an OLED
panel, but I actually like this
like a lot. Personally, I don't
think it's taking away too much at all from,
you know, the OLED experience here and the
coating itself. It's not as matte as what you'll find
on other gaming displays. It's
hard to describe, but the coating here,
it's just very clear and I don't feel like
it gets in the way too much. Don't get me
wrong, I'd still love to see what this would look
like with a truly glossy finish,
like on a TV, but image quality-wise,
I'm not disappointed.
...at all. And let's not forget,
glossy panels do have their drawbacks as well.
Now typically I don't mention image quality
too much when it comes to gaming monitors and stuff
like that, you know, usually if it's a 1440p
monitor, it looks like a 1440p
monitor, and if it has good colors,
well, we kind of know what that looks like, but
this OLED panel, it's different.
Like, the image quality-
Aber macht es überhaupt Sinn, wenn man sein PC nur für normale Sachen
und Programmieren benutzt?
Naja, Spielen sind ja
normale Sachen, oder?
Und Reaktionszeiten sind
bei Games alles. Also, ich mein, wenn
du jetzt Civilization oder
was auch immer, irgendwelche Strategien
spielst, Offline, dann vielleicht
eher nicht. Aber wenn du Multiplayer-
Games spielst, wo es auch so ein bisschen
um Reaktionszeiten und sowas geht, ist das einfach
das Bessere, was es gibt.
Hey, like, that's how clear this monitor is.
And, you know, you might be gaming at medium
settings, but you kind of feel like you're gaming
at, like, ultra, or even beyond
that, because all- Das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt
bla bla, da gewöhnt man sich auch dran.
Die Dinger sehen halt erstmal ein bisschen unterschiedlich aus.
The lighting and the depth.
Das ist das OLED-Ding, das ist-
Ehrlich gesagt, das einzige, was man erkennt,
hier mit der Kamera
wirklich abgefilmt ist, dass der-
dass das Display hier ein bisschen
dunkler erscheint, wie das.
Just looks so good. But now let's dive a little bit
deeper and talk about those response times.
Ever since picking up an OLED
display for my living room, I've always
dreamt about what it would be like to have that same
tech packed into a much smaller
gaming monitor. What would it feel like?
What would the experience be like
versus some of the fastest monitors on the
market? Could this enable a truly
zero motion blur experience?
Let's start with the numbers. Here I've
used NVIDIA's LDAT to measure the monitors
gray-to-gray pixel response times, and
the last few monitors that I've tested this with have
been actually absurdly quick.
Like the 360Hz ZOWIE and the
PG27, they both average around
1.5 milliseconds.
And as we've seen, this allows for
very minimal motion blur. As for
the new LG OLED, that averages just
0.1 milliseconds.
Not only that, but with just-
Gut, kann man sich jetzt sicherlich
drüber streiten, inwieweit man
das wahrnimmt.
Ich persönlich tippe
jetzt einfach mal drauf, dass
man es nicht bewusst,
soll ich sagen, so bewusst spürt,
dass man das jetzt an einer
einzelnen Sache festmachen kann,
aber dass man es trotzdem merken wird.
Gibt's das Ding jetzt eigentlich schon?
Das letzte Mal, wo ich danach
gesucht habe,
war das, ja, Ultra G,
das war das Coming Soon,
das ist demnächst verfügbar,
guck mal, mein Geizhals.
Ultra Gear, hier.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was hier der
Unterschied ist dazwischen.
Das ist aber auf jeden Fall nicht der
richtige, der ist zu billig.
Wie heißt denn das Teil hier?
27 bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Leer da.
Gibt's noch nicht.
Gibt es noch nicht.
Na, muss ich nochmal warten.
Warte mal, wo sind wir stehengeblieben?
Ist das überhaupt der richtige, den ich
hier habe?
Ja, genau.
Ah, das ist die 32 Zoll
Variante.
Die will ich nicht.
Ich will die 27 Zoll Variante,
alles andere ist mir zu groß.
48, 27.
Ne, das sind andere.
Aber man muss mir ehrlich sagen,
guckt euch mal an, die Monitorbezeichnungen
sind wieder richtig hängen geblieben.
27GR95EQE,
ja, alles klar.
Reorder.
Wie gesagt, auf den bin ich scharf.
Sobald der lieferbar ist,
kauf ich mir den auch.
Ultra clear image quality,
that you also get from the OLED panel.
You just get this super consistent,
you know, slideshow at 240Hz.
Every image is just so clear all the time.
Now to further test response times
and to better visualize what these numbers
actually look like in reality,
we use the UFO ghosting test
from blowbusters.com.
Das dieses Ding aber noch gibt.
So, was ist das für ein UFO?
So, comparing the 360Hz 1440p
from Asus to the new OLED,
we can see that with just a 0.1
millisecond response time,
we do get a pretty clear image,
but surprisingly compared to the IPS,
which here has a 1.5 millisecond response time,
it's not like leaps and bounds better
as the numbers would suggest.
What's interesting though is that
when we crank up the UFO movement speed,
so the UFO object is now kind of panning
across the screen a bit faster now,
so even with a 0.1 millisecond
grade to grade response time,
motion blur at least here on the OLED,
in the UFO test at least,
is not perfect, especially when you consider
how far away it is from the DIAC plus
result on the ZOWIE 360Hz.
Where the 0.1 millisecond response time
can be...
Ich hab fast den da.
Also, ja, das
hab ich auch an, diesen Gaming Mode
teilweise, DIAC.
Wobei ich da immer noch ein bisschen
unschlüssig bin, ob das so eine gute
Sache ist, weil damit hast du,
du siehst ja hier teilweise,
hast du das Problem, dass es ein bisschen,
wie soll man das beschreiben,
dass die Umrisse manchmal
irgendwie merkwürdig sind.
Aber so einen ähnlichen, ich hab
einen Vorgänger hiervon.
...be noticed though is with ultra slow motion
footage, so on the left here we have
the 360Hz ASUS, and on the right
we have the 240Hz LG.
DIAC ist ein Ausschalten von der
Hintergrundbeleuchtung, ja.
In every single comparison, the OLED
has almost no ghosting, and is like...
Warum bist du so scharf auf dem Monitor, holst dir
kein 24K IPS 27?
Was will ich mit 4K?
Ich will irgendwas haben, wo ich auch mit ordentlich
viel FPS spielen kann in 4K.
Ich will gar nicht, ich will gar nicht in 4K
spielen. Die Kombination aus
240Hz und OLED ist halt
poggers. Hyper hyper detailed.
Now I will mention, we are pixel peeping
ultra slow motion footage here, like it's
borderline a bit of a meme, but you
can actually see this in gameplay.
Like the OLED just has this visual quality
to it, where everything has so much detail
and depth, even in fast paced moments.
Now another thing I was really interested to test
out here was the input lag, you know how
fast the display can react to clicks
and movement, and how fast essentially
it can draw a new frame. Because on
one hand it has instant response times,
but at the same time 240Hz
is not exactly the fastest thing on the market.
Here we are looking at the amount of time it
takes for a mouse click to register as a
flash on screen. So over
150 samples here, green is
the 360Hz ASUS, and blue
is the 240Hz OLED.
And averaging it all out, we can see that there's
a pretty small difference, but it is a
difference nonetheless. It is actually the
360Hz PG27 that's
one millisecond quicker, and this is about
the difference that you would expect, comparing
240Hz to 360Hz.
Interestingly though, when both panels are running
at 240Hz, the
IPS panel on the ASUS still seems to
respond just a fraction quicker.
And when I say a fraction, I really
mean like we're looking at super slow motion
footage here, captured at over
6000 frames per second.
In real time, this is not even close to
being noticeable, but it's still pretty
interesting to see. Now another big difference
between these two panels is how bright
they can get. And unfortunately, the new
OLED just doesn't get that bright.
Wobei man sagen muss, sobald du
Diag anschaltest, ist die Helligkeit auch
reduziert.
So look, if you're playing in a very bright environment,
the OLED just isn't a good choice.
But I would say that for most people, it is
actually fine. Especially if you play games
with your shades closed or during the night,
I personally found 200 nits
to be sufficient. I will admit,
during my entire time playing on the
monitor, I always had it set to 100%,
so it is something to consider if you need
a really bright panel, but I think
most people's setups will be fine.
There is one setting that you'll definitely need to
disable though, and that's the luminance power
saving setting. Essentially this is like an
auto-dimming feature that is based off
of power consumption. It's really weird
and super annoying, and the monitor won't actually
be able to achieve its full brightness
in some scenes. So just make sure to
disable that and you'll be fine.
Now speaking of out-of-the-box settings...
Das ist bestimmt standardmäßig an, dass sie irgendein Prüfsiegel
bekommen haben. ...default configuration.
When I first powered this monitor on, I was
shocked at how bad it
actually looked. Like for some reason, LG
set the default white point to
8500 Kelvin, which just
looks awful. Like everything has this blue
tint, everything is overly cool.
It just looks so terrible.
Ich weiß eh nicht, was los ist.
Also warum sind die
default settings von allen Monitoren
so kacke? Apple macht das
besser, deswegen sind auch alle immer der Meinung,
dass Apple Monitore einfach das allergeilste
auf der Welt sind, wobei ich will nicht sagen, dass sie schlecht
sind, aber wenn du einen Monitor
gescheit einstellst, sehen die meisten
tatsächlich ganz gut aus.
Apple kalibriert die Dinger glaube ich von
aus. Ich weiß nicht, warum die Settings
oftmals so beschissen sind.
Auch bei teuren Monitoren sind die
default Settings so beschissen, ich versteh
gar nicht warum.
Das würde richtig viel bringen, kämen die
ordentlich vorkonfiguriert.
Dann würdest du nämlich auch einen viel besseren Eindruck
haben, ah ich hab jetzt 800 Euro ausgegeben,
ah ich hab ein geiles Bild.
Aber warum die Dinger, das ist teilweise richtig mies.
Und was das bedeutet, ist, dass die Weizen
eigentlich weiß werden, sie haben keine
Wärme oder Blau,
es wird rocksolid und alles wird perfekt
aussehen. Ich möchte auch kurz erwähnen, dass die
Farb-Performance an diesem Punkt, der sRGB-Modus
für die Leute, die das nutzen wollen, sehr
akkurat ist, es ist nur ein bisschen übersaturiert
in einigen Farben, aber im Allgemeinen
ist es immer noch sehr gut für die Farbarbeit, aber
natürlich wollen die meisten von euch den Monitor
in den breiteren Gamut-Modus verwenden, wo
man ein riesiges 95% von DCI-P3-Konvergenz
erreichen kann. Nun, es gibt etwas anderes, das ich
auf diesem Monitor nennen muss, das ein bisschen
seltsam ist, und das ist das Subpixel-Layout.
Also in jedem Pixel auf
deinem Display gibt es ein rotes, grünes
und ein blaues Element. Und
meistens sind sie in genau diesem
Verhältnis bestätigt. Rot, dann grün,
dann blau. Das neue LG OLED, auf der anderen
Seite, ist anders. Es ist tatsächlich rot,
dann blau, dann grün.
Nun, warum ist das wichtig? Warum bringe ich das
sogar auf? Es ist, weil Text und andere Elemente
in Windows viel schlechter aussehen als
man erwartet, mit diesem verschiedenen
Subpixel-Layout. Also ein bisschen eine Vergleiche
von einigen zoomierten Texten hier. Am Top haben wir...
Ehh!
Okay, das kann ich mir
nicht geben.
Das halte ich nicht aus,
weil ich da den ganzen Tag... Ich meine, man kann ja...
Also unter Linux kannst du ja glaube ich
irgendwie Subpixel-Rendering
irgendwie einstellen, aber
wahrscheinlich unter Windows auch, aber boah, nee,
Alter.
Okay.
Okay. Damit hat sich es erledigt....
Last thing that I tried out on this monitor was HDR, which is something that I'm actually pretty
keen on. You know, truly good HDR can transform game visuals. It can take something that looks 2D
and turn it into something that you can almost reach out and touch. Now, HDR is not something
that I have a lot of kind of in-depth experience testing, but what I can say is that the gaming
experience is definitely worthwhile. Like if the games that you play have good HDR support,
I don't think you'll be disappointed here at all. LG claimed that the new OLED can peak at
1000 nits while in HDR mode, so things like gunshots, fire, bright lights and stuff like
that, they'll just pop off the screen a lot more than your typical SDR mode. HDR is really
something that you can only experience and see properly in person, but you can kind of appreciate
that extra brightness through a good camera, as you can hopefully see here. Side by side,
you should be able to see a slight difference, which again is a lot more noticeable in person.
Doom Eternal, for example, has really good HDR support, and this game
just really comes to life on a really good HDR display. On the new LG OLED, it's an absolute
blast. You've got those inky blacks, you've got that super clear image, that 240Hz refresh rate,
and again, that extra pop here and there from the HDR. I think this is like a perfect example of
what this display looks like at its full potential. Now, there's not much to say about the exterior
design. It extends with height, swivel and tilt adjustment. Most of the menu controls are accessed
through a small remote.
For those interested in what settings I've been using with this monitor, I'll leave those down
below in the description, but it's only a couple of adjustments to the kind of default Gamer 1
profile. But yeah, overall, you know, there are just so many good gaming monitors out at the
moment. And even between these two, it's hard to say that one is just so much better than the other
when they do things kind of differently and they have their strong points and whatnot. But I will
say that the new 27-inch OLED is just kind of a little bit better than the old one. And I think
it's a different experience to what I've had previously, especially in a 27-inch form factor.
I've reviewed a lot of gaming monitors, lots of IPS monitors, and I would almost just kind of put
them all in the same bucket after trying something that's kind of as different as this. So I think in
the simplest terms, it's kind of like the 360Hz Asus IPS. It's a bit more of a smoother experience,
but then the 240Hz... Okay, nee, aber mit dem Fontrendering, das halte ich nicht aus. Da drehe ich am Rad, das weiß ich jetzt schon.
Zumal ich das wahrscheinlich auch nicht richtig mit einer VM dann benutzen lässt und es da nicht
umstellt. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Okay, damit hat sich das jetzt erst mal erledigt, der Monitor.
Wie kalibriert man seinen Monitor? Du brauchst ein Gerät, was du vor den Monitor hängst, das die
Farben misst. Und dann hast du zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder du stellst es über die Monitoring-Regler
möglichst genau ein. Oder was auch oftmals geht, ist, du lässt dir ein Farbprofil, du lässt dir ein
Farbprofil generieren, was du lädst, was dann quasi die Abweichung ausgleicht. So einen habe ich,
genau. Spider, Spider 3 oder so. Irgend so ein Teil habe ich, genau. Genau sowas. Das ist ein Teil,
das hängst du vor den Monitor. Genau so ein Ding ist das. Das hängst du vor den Monitor, schließt
er an. Dann startest du ein Kalibrierungsprogramm. Also das ist quasi eine Kamera, wenn du es so
willst. So eine Art Kamera. Die Kamera hängst du vor den Monitor. Dann startest du ein Kalibrierungsprogramm.
Das macht dann halt...
Zeigt rot.
Dann auf dem Bildschirm grün und zeigt Farben auf dem Monitor an. Und am Ende misst das halt, wie
akkurat dein Monitor ist. Und dann, ja, dann stellst du entweder an den Reglern rum oder du lässt
dir ein Farbprofil generieren, was das ausgleicht. Ja, das war tatsächlich eine sehr sinnvolle
Investition, der Spider. Meiner ist auch schon einige Jahre alt. Der hat sich aber bisher gut
bewährt. Das ist sinnvoll gewesen. Kostet auch nicht viel. Ja, kostet...
Spider Monitor. Aber mittlerweile sind die bei 5 oder bei Spider X oder so sind sie mittlerweile.
Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht kriegst du sogar noch irgendwie Gebrauchte. Ja. Data Color Spider. Ja,
guck mal, du kriegst teilweise schon Gebrauchte. Das lohnt sich. Zumindest so ein... Das ist halt
so ein typisches Gerät. Da brauchst du halt eins und dann ist gut. Das braucht man ja nicht für
jeden Rechner, sondern eins für alles. Ja.
Das lohnt sich. Ist nicht verkehrt so ein Teil.
Leute, ich gucke gerade auf die Uhr. Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was jetzt eigentlich ist? Korrekt.
So sieht's aus. Nee, ich gehe jetzt was essen, Leute. Ich hab Hunger. Ich hab noch Lachs und Nudel übrig.
Ich will jetzt reinhauen. Werde ich erst mal warm machen und 20 Minuten dann was essen.
Wir sehen uns vielleicht heute Mittag, dass wir unser, unser Python-Zeug weiter basteln.
Nichts Großartiges. Das muss ja mal irgendwann fertig werden.
Vielleicht aber auch nicht. Je nachdem, ob ich MMO-Kreiselgrind mache oder nicht.
Bin ich mir noch nicht ganz, ganz sicher.
Alles klar, bis dann. Wir sehen uns. See you. Macht's gut.